Wow hello everyone so I had to deal with a load of work
messages when I woke up I was like oh my god please I have
to stream in like now hello everyone hello hello let me
adjust my stuff real quick I am a bit of a mess but you know
I'm always a mess anyway all right story time every the
thing guys all want to know my tooth what the fuck was going
on with my tooth for those who didn't know um last week i
felt uh my gums were swollen because i felt um something
wrong with my second molar the very also some people thought
i uh yeah the tooth situation is fucking crazy guys uh yes
it's tooth story time also my food's gonna be here in uh 10
minutes and I ordered a bagel yeah I ordered a bagel right
after your tube extraction don't you like you're fucking
crazy yay more chewing yeah let's go but soft food no you
don't understand guys it's a really good bagel.
It has chicken salad and a salmon in it.
It's a really good bagel, guys.
You don't understand.
It's a custom-built bagel.
Anyway, okay, okay, let me, I pulled up some notes about
this particular story.
You know what?
No, no, no.
Okay, let's have a good environment for this story time.
Let me get a good environment here.
okay what room do i want to be in what i tell all right here
you go not room okay story time okay we're just gonna be
like um story time first before game if you were confused
you're like where the is my game okay we'll do story time
first so we gotta be comfy about this particular story so
basically let me see i wrote notes about this so we'll we'll
start from the beginning We'll start from the beginning.
So what happened was that a week ago, I had steak.
It was a mistake, as we all know.
So I had steak and I felt something right after eating the
steak.
I felt something wrong with my tooth.
I thought at first that I got something stuck in there,
which I was correct.
What I didn't realize was that I cracked my tooth.
I cracked it so the food was stuck in my tooth what I didn't
realize was that it was stuck in the crack so a couple of
days after that um by the way that tooth was a root canal
tooth so if anyone's ever got a root canal before it um it's
already your tooth is incredibly weak after you get a root
canal So you got to be, which was pretty fucked up because
that was my chewing tooth too.
So it was my chewing tooth that was incredibly weak.
So I forgot about that because I got that root canal like
four to five years ago.
So I forgot all about that part.
So because I didn't know which tooth had the root canal.
I just remembered I had a root canal.
Anyway, so a couple of days after that.
my gums started being swollen but i felt no pain it was just
incredibly annoying because it was just this giant swollen
thing on my side so i couldn't close my mouth properly um
and i had a feeling it was cracked because i was getting my
tongue and feeling the tooth but i felt no pain because
later that's like why didn't i feel pain oh silly me it was
my root canal tube so there was no more nerves in there like
these people like how are you not in pain because i was live
tweeting my by the way i was live tweeting my whole dentist
adventure so every time he gave me bad news i was tweeting
it out um so be like how are you not in like fucking
unbearable pain and i was like thing is because it was my
root canal tooth the nerves are fucking dead that's what
root canal is you literally kill off the nerve associated uh
with that tooth so that's why i felt zero pain uh yeah
that's what root canal is you literally kill off the nerves
on that tooth and then like fill it up with um fill it up
with shit in it uh to like make it a tooth um so yeah you
remove all the nerves and then you fill it up with whatever
the fuck i don't know i'm not a dentist like i don't know
you fill it up with some fucking tooth stuff um
so that's what that's what the root canal is so that's why i
felt zero pain but that was bad that i felt zero pain
because like then i was just like oh it should not be it
maybe it'll get better you know i was just like uh maybe
it'll get better but obviously i should have went to the
dentist right like i should have went to the emergency
dentist right away because the indicator of whether or not
you should go to the emergency dentist is whether or not you
feel pain.
But I felt zero pain.
So I was just like, oh, I can just wait until my appointment
because I didn't feel any pain.
But silly me, it's because I removed the pain receptors from
that tube.
And that is why I didn't feel any pain.
So my body couldn't even send signals to me be like you
gotta go to the dentist right away so so I was just like so
I waited I waited for my appointment like a good girl
because I was like well clearly other people already had
their appointments you know they're ahead of me so I should
just wait until until it was my turn so because I was like I
can wait I'm not feeling any pain like I don't feel any pain
I can wait for
So, um, you're like, why didn't you check on the, because it
was all, all the way back at the back molar.
It's the second molar.
It's all, it's the top left.
It's not the bottom guys.
It was the top left molar.
So I couldn't see anything.
And like, like it was a root canal too.
So I can't see if like anything is wrong because it was so
you can't see it it's literally at the very back i looked in
the mirror shine the light on it i couldn't even see where i
was swollen because the swollen part was behind the fucking
molar um yeah it was behind it's a very far back to it was
behind the molar where my swollen gum was that was pressing
against it so i couldn't even see the crack no it's so i
couldn't even see it like um it's at the dentist they had to
take to see the crack because they couldn't see it like
until they had to take like the close-up pictures to fully
see the full-on crack but anyway anyway I'm getting ahead of
myself so originally like I said um I realized on uh I think
it was Sunday I was like I gotta go to the emergency dentist
I can't close my mouth anymore because it's so swollen I
mean technically I could close my mouth, but it was so
uncomfortable because of how swollen the gums were, were
pressing against me.
So I was like, I gotta go to the emergency dentist and they
had one appointment.
And that one appointment was at the time of my apex
tournament.
And I was like, oh, clearly at the apex tournament is more
important.
So the thing is I didn't want to cancel the apex tournament
because I, I was, able to get the appointment 30 minutes
before the apex tournament was about to start and i felt
really shitty if i just drop out at the last second like you
know if i gave them a heads up like you know 24 hour heads
up then that's fine but it was literally 30 minutes before
the tournament was about to start and the the emergency
dentist was like look we have we have one slot open and it's
at the same it's at 12 p.m which is at the same time as my
apex tournament so i was just like well the next day anyway
so so i was thinking i was thinking oh i do have an
appointment on monday anyway so i can just wait the next day
i can just tank it for one more day because you guys all
know i was talking about it too i was like i can tank this
for one more day um it's just like you know i'm not feeling
pain i know the reason why i wasn't feeling pain was because
the nerves are know at that time you know i was talking to
like my friends and my manager and i was just like should i
go do a dentist like should i get an emergency dentist like
my gums are swollen but i don't feel pain and they're like
you don't feel pain right i was like yeah i don't feel pain
and they're like no it should be fine just wait until your
appointment like as long as you don't feel pain like like
then you should be good but we didn't know it was the root
canal tooth and that's why i didn't feel pain so we were all
going in there with like the lack of knowledge like
everyone's like yeah yeah i didn't know
um so they're like yeah as long as you um you don't feel
pain then it should be fine but none of us knew that it was
because we all lacked the critical information
So it was four to five years ago because right after the
root canal a couple years later that I got my wisdom tooth
removed So I remember that I forgot about which tooth was
the root canal because the wisdom tooth removal was
superseded that
Anyway, anyway, by the way my gums aren't swollen anymore
after they fucking took the tooth the tooth is gone Like
they took it all in and then the swollenness disappeared.
Anyway, I um back to the story uh yeah i took over my memory
slot i deleted it i can only have one slot for a dentist but
i have to delete it again um anyway so i was thinking okay
monday i have an appointment that should be fine because
like i managed to get uh someone canceled on monday so i was
like oh okay um because my original appointment was tuesday
so i was like oh someone canceled on monday day early.
I was like, yeah, yippee.
Anyway, Monday rolls around.
By the way, you guys were like, but you tweeted on Tuesday,
Doki.
Yes, this is the reason why.
You're like, wait a minute, Doki.
This story doesn't make any sense because you tweeted on
Tuesday instead of Monday.
We're fact checking this and this doesn't make sense.
Anyway, so Monday rolled along and I received the, I was
getting ready to go to the dentist.
I was so happy.
I was like, yay, my problems would be fixed soon.
and uh yeah the evidence doesn't add up and so i was like
yippee i'm gonna get fixed soon and then i received a call
and the receptionist was like we're very sorry the dentist
um is sick right now so they can't operate uh they can't
check look at you on monday and i was like what i was like
what do you mean i was like this is what do you mean they're
like but we still have the original appointment that you had
on Tuesday so you can come over on Tuesday um you come over
on Tuesday uh for your original appointment so I was like no
you can't do this to me you can't fucking do this to me I
waited like a good girl I followed the rules I followed the
steps of bureaucracy, and I still have to come over on
Tuesday?
I...
Oh, thank God, especially in Canada.
So, so now I have to take one more day.
Yeah, I have to take...
How fucking dare you get sick?
I'd rather you just put on a face mask and operate on me.
I don't fucking care.
I...
so anyway so that's why that's why i did not get my
appointment on monday anyway so tuesday rose up tuesday rose
up i go in to the dentist i was so fucking nervous because
like i said you know my gums were still swollen it wasn't
that bad by the way i think it's it's swollen because like
every time i close my mouth like I try to talk or close my
mouth, I was irritating the gum because it's just like
scraping against it.
So it was like every time I wake up, like my gums weren't
that swollen.
It was just like a small bump.
But like as the day goes on, it just gets bigger because I
keep, I keep like irritating the gums.
So it, you know, it's like a pimple.
Like it's like a fucking pimple.
If you touch it too much, it gets bigger.
So like that was the situation I was in because every time I
wake up, it's like, like oh it feels okay it feels like
nothing and then and then when I talk too much or if I like
close my mouth too much like if I open or close my mouth too
much it was just irritating the gums too much so it gets
bigger so that was the issue too like every time I wake up
it's fine um and so Tuesday rose up and uh um and then um I
was at the dentist and I've never been to this dentist
before because like i don't know which one my mom fucking
got me in the past i just like called up the like all the
dentist places and got the closest one but also the ones
that were good like you know i'm not going to some like i'm
not going to some like dentist at timu in the back alleys or
whatever like because like i'm because you know i want to be
sure because like i'm i don't want to, I want them, I want
to be sure that the tools are, um, what's it called?
The tools are sanitized and everything.
If it's going to go in my mouth, I got to make sure that all
the tools are incredibly sanitized and like, like the
dentist knows what the fuck they're doing because I don't
know what the fuck was wrong.
Like I, I had a feeling it was cracked because I was feeling
it with my tongue um um and um like i had a feeling that um
um that it was cracked just because like it was just me like
progressing it just from what i felt because i was like this
this too feels like it's in half like that just feels like
two pieces that one singular too so so um i went in and then
we like we took pictures and everything we took pictures of
my jaw and everything and you know pictures of like uh my
teeth and stuff and um and then the assistant was like oh
yeah that's a crack tooth it's like oh okay at least we know
what the problem is he's like yeah that's yeah the x-ray
they did x-rays and then they took like close-up pictures of
where it is and you're like oh, we're going to look at that,
the second molar at the top left, right?
And I was like, yep, and they're like, yep, it shows in the
x-ray.
It's like, oh, it's where you got the root canal.
And I'm like, oh, that makes so much sense now.
No wonder I didn't feel anything.
Because she was like, oh yes, you can see here.
That's where you got your root canal, too.
And I was like, oh, that's why I didn't feel anything.
That's why I felt nothing.
Like, no pain whatsoever.
Because that tooth is fucking dead uh because that was where
canals are um and so she's like oh so i was like oh okay so
it's cracked what do we do and she's like oh yes um um um
well there's two options with a cracked tooth uh right now i
can't see how bad um how bad the crack is but um if it's not
too bad because she's like I can't tell really how bad the
crack is from just the photos and the x-ray so we'll get the
dentist to come in and check in just to be sure but if it's
not too bad we'll just put a crown over the tooth um and
then like and then it's like a little helmet so um a little
helmet over the tooth thing and um but if it's like way too
deep like way too cracked we're gonna have to remove it
because there's no saving that tooth so you know i in my
heart i was like because i never had a tooth extracted
before and also that root canal apparently was fucking
incredibly expensive so i was like what the fuck was the
point of getting a root canal if i was just gonna get get
that tooth removed anyway i might as well remove it in the
first place so in my heart i was like i would be nice to
just put a crown on it because like what was the point of
putting root canal a very expensive root canal by the way if
it was just gonna get removed in the end so in my heart but
you guys already see the foreshadowing because they did not
listen to my heart because i'm missing a tooth right now um
so um so anyway so they're like we're just gonna wait until
the dentist comes in to check on it to see like what the
plan was the dentist comes in and i'm like And he's like,
all right, let's check on this cracked tooth right here.
He looked in my mouth.
He looked in it for five seconds and was like, oh, yeah,
it's gone.
Just meant this man looked in my mouth.
Five seconds.
He's like, oh, yeah, no, it's gone.
Just like that.
Nothing we can do about it.
like the assistant looked in my mouth the assistant looked
at all the photos and all the fucking eggs are like i don't
know i can't tell for sure if we have to remove it or not
we're just gonna have to wait i mean that's why she's the
assistant and not the fucking actual dentist but so you know
i had a little hope that we could save it but nope it was
gone it yeah no he was like and then after that he was like
yeah no it's cracked in half like it's it's cracked in half
girl like we gotta take that shit out like yeah so yep it
was it was fully uh cracked in half um that was a yeah no
that tooth was over um um and so they're like we have two
options One, the thing is, I was like, one was to, like,
knock me fully out, but I will, but it would not be, like,
the day of the appointment, or two, they give me, like,
laugh, I think, I don't know what it's called, I think
there, it's not laughing gas, maybe it is called laugh,
like, the, the non-professional name was, like, laughing gas
or what, but it's, like, the NOXA, whatever it's called,
the, the gas that's supposed to make you, like, highs.
Yeah.
Nitrix.
Nitrix oxide.
Yes.
So it was either nitrous oxide today, like on the day.
And then they take goink it out.
Um, um, and like they were like, oh yeah, don't worry.
Like if we do that option, you'd be able to like head home
like yourself and just like drive home.
Little did I know I don't drive, but they're like, you could
just drive yourself home.
You don't need you up or anything um you can really just uh
just go home or two um they give me some medication now to
like deal with it and then um i have to come back on a
different they have to make a new appointment so they can
knock me to out with anesthesia um but i'd be like super
fucking loopy and really high um if i do the option um um
because like they have to have like they have to have like
vitals monitored and everything to make sure I don't fucking
die in my sleep while they're operating so they're like yeah
and they're like oh yeah and um um and also like but then
there also there's another option where they give me the
medication and also put me in on nitrix oxide uh that will
make me super high and like super loopy too but I won't be
knocked out.
I just not be like incredibly high.
So, oh, sorry, sorry.
They gave me three options.
The one is general anesthesia.
But when I wake up, I'll also be like super loopy.
Or the other option would be like, they give me this special
medication to like, it would make me like super loopy and
also put me on nitrous oxide, which will make me double
loopy.
And I would need someone to take care of me.
Like take me home.
But I won't be knocked out.
I won't be knocked out.
that i'll be i'll be like awake but like not not really you
know so obviously i was like who the fuck do i call to pick
me up like so i was worried about that i was like oh my god
nobody lives close to me who the fuck do i call and also
like i don't want to wait another day like i want to get
this shit fixed like today but i was real and i was also
like really scared if i could i would choose the anesthesia
where like i was just knocked out like i was i would if i
could because that was what i did for my wisdom too i just
got knocked out and i just went home um but i just i was
really worried because i was just like i've never been like
high before little do you guys know like i know some people
like oh she must have got high i've never been high before
so that like scares me too so i was really scared about all
the options because I've never been high before and like the
first option you know I've never been on a nitrix oxide
whatever and I was like how would I react and she's the
assistant was like oh yeah like there's different types of
reactions um to it like you could be really relaxed or like
you know it could make you like you know feel like you're
high or like other stuff so I was so scared because I was
like I've never been high before like I don't know out what
the fuck is this option gonna be so obviously i want to get
that tooth out out right now so i chose the first option in
the end because like that was the only option where like
they could be like yeah we can take your tooth out now um i
didn't know how long it was gonna take so um i sat there
like um waiting you know like i was like i'm gonna go and
you're like by the way it's $600 you don't have insurance
right i was like no $600 so i was just like holy fuck okay
this is a $600 bill to fucking remove a tooth and they kept
okay so they put the gas mask on me like the masking where
it's just on my nose and i was like and i in my head i'm
like i'm gonna inhale $600 worth of gas So keep on giving me
that shit
Yeah 600 Canadian I was like I'm gonna I was like I'm gonna
try and get $600 worth of fucking nitrous oxide In my system
So So um and they kept asking me um they kept asking me like
do you feel anything and i'm like i don't know i would be
straight with all of you guys i don't fucking know if i felt
anything so they kept increasing the doses they're like do
you feel anything any different i'm like not really and i'm
not saying that's if i wanted more i literally did not know
so they're like don't worry we'll increase the doses and
they kept asking me i was like i don't know if i'm feeling
anything and they're like okay we'll increase the dosage
again so they kept like increased they increased like four
times the dosage because i legitimately don't know i i will
be real with you guys i don't i think i i don't know if i
think it might have made me relaxed or some made me more
relaxed but i was not feeling shit i i i i was not i i swear
to god i felt like it nothing to me um i might have been
more i might have been a bit relaxed a bit more relaxed only
because they fucking joint the tooth out of me and i was
just but i also had numbing shit put in my mouth you know
like my mouth is fully numb so i can't tell if it's the
numbing the numbing thing doing this work or like the the
nitrous oxide making me feel relaxed it could be have to
numb me like you had to like poke stab the back of my mouth
you know stab the the back of the mouth and also like you
know stab the gums of where they had to take the tooth out
so they had to do all that shit too um so they had my mouth
was no pain it literally felt like nothing and also like i
had the nitrous oxide on as well so like like generally i
don't know i don't know if i felt anything but yeah so i
went there waiting for this shit to kick in I was like
waiting I'm like When the fuck would this kick in I was just
waiting I feel like I will let you guys know right now When
the dentist came in I was like Operation time And Sam
remember Shack that tooth And they're like You're going to
feel a little pushing When we do this And then Not even Six
minutes I swear to God It took this man five minutes and
it's like pop it's gone now and i'm like what
they spent more time fucking numbing my mouth and putting me
on nitrix oxide while i sat there and then they're like it's
gone you did it and i was like bro i fucking i'm paying 600
for this fucking five minute tooth extraction like that's it
bro that's yeah that's why he got 600 real he's a magician
yeah oh i think the worst part okay the worst part about the
tooth extraction was like they had to crack the tooth fully
in half so like because i could oh it's disgusting it people
cringe a little but I literally could it felt like bone I
could hear bones cracking because they were cracking the
tube so I could hear the tooth cracking in my jaw and it's
not a good sound it was not a very good sound and I could
feel it and then I they had to take it and have like they
took one half and the other half so I could hear it and but
then when they took the other half I didn't feel it I didn't
feel it but it sound yeah it sounds like snapping wood or
bones basically um it's not a good sound yeah it's very loud
so um so they did that and then but then when they pull out
the second half i could not feel a thing they're just like i
i didn't even realize it was just done so yeah so that's
that's basically what happened literally sat like when the
dentist came in five minutes it's over and out there like
and i gave a thumbs up They're like, it's over.
How do you feel?
Obviously, I can't say shit because, you know, my fucking
mouth was bleeding.
So I gave a thumbs up to him.
I was like, yeah, jobs done.
I, um, yeah, that, yeah.
So anyway, that's basically it.
I am miss.
They said that I don't have to get an implant only because
like a second motor is not.
really not really a big deal like it's not that noticeable
but I still have to heal so I could check back in a couple
of months just to see how it goes and maybe you know if it
you know if I feel like chewing is not fun at all with
missing molar I might get an implant in the future I'm not
sure yet I don't know I'm just waiting for it to heal right
now um anyway so um so it's all Gucci like um I sometimes
yesterday I felt like I was talking weird but like now I
feel a little bit more relaxed when I'm talking I'm still
not chewing on my left side obviously because it's healing
and takes like a one like one to two weeks for it to fully
heal um so so like we're just gonna see how that's gonna go
we're gonna see how that's gonna go um uh you know day one
obviously day one was pretty bad because you know i got a
fucking tooth removed so my mouth was bleeding so because
you know um my mouth was bleeding so like you know if i like
if i had to like um if i was brushing my teeth and i was
like rinsing my mouth and i was like poor and i'm like oh
that's blood.
That ain't good.
That's blood.
But what can I do?
What can I do about it?
There's like a fucking hole of where my tooth was.
Oh, the worst part, by the way, the worst part, like the day
after the tooth extraction, day after the tooth extraction,
I wanted to order an ice cream because I was like, I want,
you know, I thought like yeah you know i wanted to order ice
cream and you know because it helps with tooth extractions
or any tooth related things you get because it's like a it's
like a coolant you know it cools your your mouth and stuff
and i was like but you're supposed to get something that's
just plain like plain vanilla ice cream you know like you're
not supposed to grab anything with like bits in it with food
like with like toppings or mixings in it and i was like all
right i'm gonna order a nice dairy queen and yeah because
it's chilly and so i waited and i was like i was like yippee
my dairy queen vanilla ice cream is here i looked at it and
i was like why the fuck is it green like
why the fuck is my ice cream green and really tall so
apparently the uber driver um is very similar to last time
you know the one time i wanted ice cream so i got mint oreo
chocolate chip large dairy queen ice cream uh blizzard when
i ordered a small vanilla and i was like how the fuck do you
get that wrong why did i get a mint chocolate chip uh oreo
blizzard when i ordered a plain vanilla ice cream and like I
couldn't even eat it I couldn't eat it because the Oreo bits
would fucking get stuck in the fucking hole so I was just
like no how could they do this to me like I couldn't get
worse so it's because I looked at the receipt and it was the
same mistake like last time when I told you how I got the
wrong sushi order where like the person who had a very
similar name to me my premium premium ass um sushi box while
i got the cheap ass sushi uh so basically their name without
doxing myself was like daki daki curd and then so their name
was daki curd and mine was doki bread so they got they got
daki curds order for me so Daki Gurd strikes again Yeah, so
Damn you Daki Gurd So so so they picked up Daki Gurd's order
which I was just like how the fuck did you fucking mess up
my name With fucking Daki Gurd?
There's like so many different letters
So So I got my, I got a refund, but it was not a full
refund.
They just refunded me $10.
So, so it wasn't a full refund.
Cause I, cause they still took, he still took my tip.
Cause like, it was like Uber Eats tips go, go off like
automatically.
So like he still got my tip.
So I was just like, this guy, this guy did not deserve my
tip.
So, so that was the worst part.
I think that was the worst part of the story.
Just the fact that I was not able to get my vanilla ice
cream.
Like, I couldn't even eat that ice cream because there's
Oreos in it.
If it didn't have Oreos, it would have been fine.
I could just eat it around the chocolate chip, but it had
Oreos in it.
And I didn't want to get that Oreo in the fucking hole.
Because that's the biggest fear.
That's my biggest fear is if I, because you can feel there's
a lot of pain.
If you get anything in the hole, you feel so much pain from
it.
And I did not want that to happen to me.
Anyway, my bagel is here.
Let's put...
Let me grab...
Let me grab my bagel.
The sandwich...
No, it's okay.
The sandwich is different.
It's like day four.
Guys, it's okay.
It's day four.
We're fine now.
Look, back then was day two, okay?
Day two was dangerous.
Day four, I'm practically healed.
Let me go grab my sandwich real quick.
I'm back.
I got my bagel with my chicken salad and salmon.
Look, you don't understand.
It's a really good bagel.
It's...
You don't understand.
This place has really good fucking bagels, guys.
A missing tooth ain't gonna stop me.
Pain will, but that's okay.
all of it.
Don't worry.
All the receptors are gone.
So we should be fine.
Is it toasted?
It sure is.
Oh my gosh, it smells so good.
I'll take a bite out of this.
Ooh, I also had avocado added in.
Okay, let me try to eat on my right side.
Okay.
I took my bite.
I like this to be more cold I'm gonna put this in the fridge
I like cold bagels more than more than hot bagels it's good
I ordered from this place a couple of days ago and I was
like oh this is a good bagel place I'm not really not a
bagel person because I don't like how hard bagels are in
general I just think cold chicken salad is better when it's
cold so I might and I put it in the fridge but I'm normally
not fat at bagels just because like usually like bagel bread
is incredibly tough um so I'm not like a huge fan of it um
but um but like um this one this one is good but like I
think I would prefer if the chicken salad if the chicken
salad was colder so I might put it in the fridge maybe or
just leave just like eat it later all right back to the
actual gameplay tab i won't be streaming for too long
because i do have a maid cafe live performance in four hours
i had to double check in four hours so so this won't be a
particularly non-stream um when's the tooth auction they
kept it i didn't even ask for it i was too scared i was too
scared to see the crime that i'd made to see the crime scene
um yeah thank you for the So they kept it.
I think, like, it's for the best.
Oh, my gosh.
The funniest shit.
Sorry, I really want to talk about the stream.
Sorry, not the Game Awards.
I think the funniest thing, like, the post-aftermath of the
Game Awards was the fact that, like, Kojima's reaction was
so fucking funny.
Yeah, yeah.
I didn't even notice it.
He did a scoff and he rolled his eyes.
I was like oh he pissed and then he I don't know people
noticed it but he left during before they finished
announcing game of the year he actually got up and left
people saw it like circled into it was like wait isn't that
Kojima right there he actually got up and left before he
fucked oh it was not him okay thank God thank God okay
someone said it wasn't him okay if it was him I'd be like
bro I understand like but his reaction though his reaction
was pretty good I fucking I love that reaction he's like
really hey Jeff he's like Jeff I flew all the way from Japan
I could be watching Zootopia 2 again
how fucking dare you I could I was gonna meet up with I
don't know Tom Cruz, Jeff.
I canceled my Tom Cruz meeting with this for this.
He could have been fucking, I don't know, hanging out with
all the cast of the boys.
Oh yeah, another thing I wanted to mention is that they're
fucking planning on, they released the trailer for, for
Animal Farm, and I'm so sad.
They actually made, I really want to talk about it because I
just, I was watching the for animal farm like um i think
like five minutes before the stream was like 10 minutes
before the stream was supposed to start and i was so sad
because like i don't know i don't they made the animal farm
movie the trailer for it a kids movie and i'm like animal
farm is not for kids like the message the the yeah the
message regarding animal farm is like not for kids like
Yeah, yeah, it's where out some, um, some animals are, all
animals are equal, but some are more equal than others.
Yeah, yeah, George Orwell does not write for children, but
they made the movie, like, very, like, even the music for it
is not the music for it, some fucking, I don't know, some
Spotify top 100 song.
yeah no it just made like four legs good two legs bad but
then they made oh it's so weird it's so fucking weird i
don't know how to explain it you have to watch it to
understand it's just does not and then they made the main
bad guy steph rogan and he's like
no it's for kids 11 and up and literally here i was like It
says, wait, I gotta make sure you're chrome.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, recommended for ages 11 and up.
Recommended, by the way.
That means it's parental guidance.
So as long as you have, yeah, it's PG.
So unless you have a parent with you, kids under 11 can
watch the film.
Fucking wild.
kids movie.
Holy shit, that's crazy.
Oh, Hades time.
How many times do I have to beat up my grandpa?
We gotta do this again, because it doesn't save in the
middle of this.
Okay, I don't remember how I played, too, by the way, so,
um, we already talked here, so I can skip out of this.
Moonlight guide you.
Can I suppress me?
Take one back.
I already forgot what I said.
Oh, shit.
What did I have to make again?
I think otherwise.
Was there something I had to make specifically?
I mean, I can't make anything, honestly.
I don't even remember.
I already talked to her, too.
I was drinking a lesson.
I have an in-ca- Ah.
Alright.
Hail, goddess.
I already talked to all of them already, so I'm just gonna
skip.
I just don't want them to be like, why didn't you talk to
me?
I need a lot.
Okay.
I mean, I could buy a psyche, right?
Let's see.
I might as well just buy a psyche.
I feel like I need a psyche.
I can't go to... Oh, I need to buy something to be able to
go to the surface.
But I might... I'm gonna do the bottom thing.
I'm gonna get farm grandpa first.
Because I might as well.
Because apparently the top...
um you guys were saying how the top part the real world is
very dangerous and i'm like true that's very accurate so
immersive haiti's um crazy that you didn't win best art
direction but i'm not gonna open that can i'm not involved
guys not i'm just seeing what i read on twitter i don't have
my own opinions
reciting i'm not that's not my opinion guys i'm
um i think i personally think i need more than i have the
main issue i mean i talked about it on stream i just find it
really boring when one one game wins all the one when one
thing just kept sweeps everything like yeah i mean like yeah
they deserve it but it's just so boring to watch It's just
not interesting to watch at all.
I say that about sports, too.
Like, esports and sports in general.
If one team is just going to keep winning, like, it's not
fun to watch in general.
What's the scuff?
What the fuck?
Nah, I like the stick more.
Oh, wait.
That's not my stick.
Wait, that's not my...
Oh, there's my stick.
I was like, where did my stick go?
Yeah, no suspense.
It's just a boring watch.
And I ain't about that shit.
uh what should i get for the downstairs
also i swear to god jeff did not care like about announcing
winners like because it's it's called the game awards but
the award section was so fucking fast he's like here's the
nominee here's the winner bam next here's the next trailer
guys oh guys trailer
i should get gold oh i think you're right Like, I swear, I
had more...
I could barely process who fucking won.
Um...
Let's just get good on the first level.
Yeah, they were speedrunning that shit.
And it was still the longest game awards, too.
Yeah, I remember we talked to them already.
We'll farm the downstairs first.
Okay, what do we need?
Uh...
Hold...
By will of night.
Do I get the upgrades yet?
When do I get the upgrades for weapons, chat?
Awesome.
Broken boss, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This could have been an email, Jeff Kojima.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm just gonna do...
I'll do 20% more horror.
Time run is just a normal run.
Yeah.
I have to buy all.
I did.
I just bought all the weapons.
Oh, is this for next up?
The next run?
Okay, the next run will get upgrades.
All right, let's just get...
we'll do time again i guess by my birthright um time and
then uh percent of your i don't know i don't think i should
do time right you know i'll do one normal run because i i
don't remember how to play the game what is it okay there's
that and then that and then there's my cube okay i just
don't remember how I played a game, so I just gotta look
through everything real quick.
Uh...
Can you get anything?
No.
Alright, let's go in.
Yeah, I just need to remember how to play.
And then we'll go, we'll do time.
What's the normal run?
Right now.
This is the normal run.
Alright.
Aphrodite.
What do you have for me, girl?
You met many of us now.
But not yet proud Athena, I presume.
Apparently, she's too busy defending our front lines.
Take no offense.
Oh, yeah.
Of good manners, after all.
Where is Athena?
Okay, your attacks deal more damage to nearby foes.
Your special deals more damage.
My special is my right click.
Rushing damage surrounding foes.
I feel like rushing, right?
Rushing is better.
One, two, or three?
One?
do one two or three guys
one is good I feel like I was either one or three the thing
is um I don't want to uh oh it's weird oh wait there's a
what if I get freezing pathways and suffocating Erebus lead
to dead ends and very scarce are those who can navigate them
alright What?
My entire life to figure out Don't worry Yeah, see, I'm
trying to remember how to play So that I don't trust myself
right now
Oh god Oh god, like right now I don't trust myself to be
able to remember how to play Like I think my reaction time
too is like Very bad Because it's still the morning for me
This is technically the morning Always use more Aphrodite
more Aphrodite power-ups.
That's crazy that Hades didn't win it.
Wait, I just realized Hades didn't win anything today.
Oh, yesterday.
That's like insane.
That's great.
Hey, but hey, Stilkson, you got one!
Insane, Jeff.
You know, Stilkson didn't go... I didn't even realize this,
but...
Oh, it went back best...
Oh, it went best action game.
Oh, yeah, sorry.
They got one, too, guys.
They got one.
It was so fast.
I don't think you guys remember this but there the
announcement of them winning wasn't even like They didn't
even get to like go up on stage to like talk about it Like
that's the worst part like silk song and 80s were like it
was just like an aforementioned like a side note Yeah, it
was like they didn't even get to go up
just a site like a fucking side note by the way they're like
oh yeah anyway here's nominees here's the winner anyway
here's some ads uh that's crazy oh yeah and apparently team
cherry didn't even go because they were like oh uh we want
we want yeah cherry didn't even go because they're like
They're like, bro Clara is just gonna win everything That's
insane That's insane that's like Jeff was That's why I read
like that's why Jeff Was like hey look you won one dude you
didn't go but you won one But I'm like bro you didn't even
get to go on stage What the fuck do you mean Jeff didn't
even Get to go on stage That's crazy The worst part is like
Claire does not just like all that hate like cuz like you
know it's the it's like it's it's the fucking judges panel's
fault not the fucking devs fault that they got they got
nominated or they they won all of it it's just like it's so
weird like it's not the devs fault they didn't even realize
like like they didn't know they were gonna win all of it so
but like the devs are like getting all the hate for it and
everything just because like just because of all that shit
your moves make you briefly restore any oh nice that's good
that's magic i need that uh which is better okay okay i can
do this don't be frightened all right
all right see look at that guys i know how to do this now
yeah which is better zeus zeus or freeze i feel like zeus
right yeah they just made the game i don't like i don't
think they like realized they were going to have that happen
to them but like like claire is just getting like the the
fucking hate of it but i don't i personally don't think they
definitely did not deserve it the hate until we meet again
that reclusive witch of the crossroads must have been a most
unwilling caretaker of yours and kept you from your real
family till now at least techity taught you some survival
skills and had enough sense to finally acquaint us all right
the cast cost damage your foe is struck by lightning and
again oh um just don't get hit okay i feel like two yeah two
two for sure see there is hermes
yeah but it's like if you have to blame anyone just blame
jeff but like jeff and the And the judges.
Because apparently, what is...
The judges have, like, journalists in there.
I mean, like, you know, it's fine.
Some of the journalists do good job.
But, like, IGN is in there.
I have no mana.
I was not paying attention.
I get that.
But don't give up on Azietam.
I know you never would mind.
Probably just searching for some magical ingredients you
need.
Something like that.
Alright, gain dodge chance and move speed that increased the
more booms you have.
You channel your cast faster and your cast expires faster.
Most foe range shots are slower.
You need that chance and move speed that increases.
This is bullshit.
I hate the three.
Most foe range.
Okay, yeah.
Target target.
Great to might.
What a shot.
We have... Oh, wait.
Well, the shop might have boons too.
The shop might have boons or, like, poms or whatever the
fuck.
Nope, it did not.
Okay, whatever.
This shot fucking sucked.
It's okay.
I got decided.
She never loses heart.
It's almost precious how she strives with all the might,
brandishing that decorative spear of hers.
Oh, wait.
Is this dual?
Yeah, it's dual.
Dual boom.
She's shit talking.
She's shit talking Aphrodite.
I inspire you.
Though perhaps you ought to pay more attention to our foes
than to what I do with my spear.
So we can turn this battle in our...
Yay!
How do I always get The duo is what?
Like, it's hard?
You take less damage from nearby bows.
Boons of Afro-treats all foes as nearby.
Oh, shit!
Wait!
Nice!
That was good.
Hello.
Oh, this tainted gold.
You'll see that it's disposed of properly, Lord Keron.
I long to see that night.
Alright, here we go.
sister oh wait hey wait where is she wait she said that she
has my back oh there she is oh she did nothing okay cool
that's not having my back if you oh my god i didn't even see
her that's too busy talking here like what do you mean like
they're dead i feel okay i'll let you have i'll let oh and
you missed okay that's cool okay thanks for having my back
bro Bro, you missed, bro.
Alright.
Nice moral support.
Yeah, I killed him twice.
I didn't expect the second time, but it worked.
How'd you do it?
Found some exploitable weakness, something like that.
I mean, he's just old.
He's very powerful, but must have underestimated my ability
to resist his tricks.
Look, he's very old.
underestimate you though must have his vulnerabilities the
old are seldom wise and often weak right he's bloodied go
for the kill yay see i told you he's old uh piercing shot
flies towards any foes damaged by your cast oh wait three
sounds good closure and task may take critical damage from
your attacks oh i don't know i don't two
I do cast a lot I don't have Oh yeah I don't have wing no
Cast is just a cue That doesn't require mana But it's just
It's a cast I can just press it
I'm not cast Uh Yeah I'm just not good I'm not doing like
the holding one Yeah but I'm not holding it Yeah Oh, three
needs mana.
Use mana for a bind.
Oh, okay, I'll use two.
Very well.
Yeah, I have zero mana, guys.
Oh, hey.
Moonstone.
More reagents.
I'll go for Zeus.
I feel like Zeus.
Actually, I can get a different...
Guys.
Dimitri or Zeus, guys?
Which is better?
Dimitri or Zeus?
I'm not even timed, so what the fuck am I positive?
for.
I don't know.
I already have a Zeus thing.
Or Demeter.
Sorry, Demeter.
Uh...
That's been a week.
I haven't had...
Maybe I'll get a good cast too.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Fuck these ladies.
Okay.
Alright, that's fine.
Whoa!
Alright.
Wee!
Goodbye.
Normally, sweet Aphrodite's power over beauty.
Oh my gosh, this is another duo?
There's no shortage of entertainment.
Why is she talking after talking shit to Aphrodite?
Is there another duo?
Oh no, she just felt like talking shit.
She just...
Oh!
Wait, one!
One.
Well, no, she just, you know, Aphrodite just took a random
shred.
Everyone just has beef with her.
Excellent.
I was like, whoa.
Oh, moon.
Oh, no.
Nice.
Oh, I missed when...
I wish my attack was more range.
I'll miss that.
It's fine.
I got freeze.
It's okay.
get out of here okay I just need something where I could
like throw my cast out and then we should be good then we
have a good build yeah I did that but like I can't go up yet
I can't breathe human air apparently perhaps our plan
required this new phase hmm
I can't touch grass yet grass hurts me a lot let me
nightmare with her own abilities for five seconds, 100.
I have no magic.
I might as well just get two.
I have no magic whatsoever.
It doesn't really matter what I pick.
I literally have six magic.
Maybe this time they'll have stuff in the shop.
You know?
Maybe.
Oh, see guys, I told you.
Yeah, I don't know what that does, but yeah.
When you sprint, hit the first foe, you run into a blast
that knocks.
When you claim rewards other than boons or...
Oh!
We want that.
When you reclaim boons, we're a cop.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, too.
It's Gambatown.
Gambatown.
Oh, I could have got food.
Whoops.
up money for food i've vanquished kronos everything you've
trained me to do yet still you stand in my way still more to
learn even now now yay gambit time that tinge of frustration
you expressed i would see you rid yourself of it in your
attempts to rid yourself of me
yeah oh my god i'm trying to remember how fighter Why are
you no freeze?
Why are you no freeze?
What's the point of getting freeze if you don't freeze?
Oh, God.
It's okay.
Alright, alright.
Oh, my God.
I thought that was a person.
I forgot they're green.
I was like, where is she?
It's over here.
Oh, it's Toho time.
Toho.
Really bad Toho though.
Oh shit.
I'm sorry Toho was pretty scary Oh my god, fuck Okay It's
okay Cheap time Oh god.
Oh god.
Oh, it's okay.
I'm okay.
It's okay.
It does poor damage.
It's practically nothing
what okay okay okay that was okay that's me i i up too much
guys you don't understand forgot about it okay if this is
just guys you don't understand it's been a while it's been a
while
there's only 10 10 damage is nothing you're right you can
tell the bond you share is strong look i got a little
impatient okay yeah i just got a little impatient look see i
got my hp back i'm just warming up i'm just warming up chat
he's there oh he is let me just say let me uh i guess i
should get what is it i fight the dog with this what should
i get after that uh
hmm do i grab the moon or what and the next map grabs you i
guess i could get no i don't use magic enough though that's
the thing concave stone yeah i should grab that quite done
we'll do this too we store 10 when you enter ensure any
goods offered by sharon cost three percent less uh your cast
deals three five i mean i have enough money no let's just
talk to him yet persist despite my generous attempts you
carry on as the distraction which you are whilst i turn my
attention to matters of greater import
all right i'm pretty important why she said that the
fountain what what oh i don't even know what the fountain is
oh this one i don't think there's anything i would want
right now though I guess I could get this, but Do I need it?
No, I already have a lot of HP.
I should grab HP upgrades, though.
Nah.
I'm just going to go grab some HP upgrades.
Oh, hey!
He's here.
Oh, 16.
Okay.
That hurts.
Hello Chaos!
Have I given Chaos a gift yet?
I don't remember.
So I have seen that the serpent of the three fates found you
in that hidden place, you relate to your secret did he not?
You mean Moros?
His secret was about the surface.
About how I can survive up there.
I know this goes against the fates' designs, but Olympus
needs me.
I'm giving track of my time.
I'm trying to make sure I don't miss my maid cafe
appearance.
But...
Oh!
Theodic favor.
Oh, nice.
He gave me something.
I don't know what it is, but he gave me a little gift.
You take afterwards your channel, your moves.
Okay, I have no magic.
Next to you, you have one fear.
Oh!
Dash makes you lose Afterwards gain Oh Three I should grab
three Yeah I don't even have magic So does it really matter
I don't even have Chokes on you I have zero magic Is that
Okay we should get ash Oh god So fast God I need I hate
these guys.
There you go.
Oh, shit.
I didn't even see that they threw up on me already.
Risky to unseal a different path.
Let's just unseal it.
That's the risk I'm willing to take!
That's right.
No fear!
Oh, it's just one guy anyway.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, no, there was no reason to do it.
Let's get you someplace safe.
Alright.
That's Psyche.
Oh.
Almost got me there.
Okay, I don't know if I have enough for a shop.
Yo, Supa, they give us Super Chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki's my birthday a few days ago.
Oh, I do have just enough.
Oh, wait.
Which is more important?
Poseidon or Boon or Pab?
Poseidon or Pab?
Which is more important?
What's she using?
You can get a happy birthday for my Kamiyoshi.
Of course you can, Yatupa.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Yatupa.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Where is that boon?
Wait, this is that boon, right?
You mean Poseidon?
I've been calling this boon, so I'm confused now.
Okay, Palma, Poseidon.
Okay, Poseidon, right?
Poseidon, okay.
Because I've been calling this boon even though it's not a
boon.
So I'm not confusing myself.
I'm confusing myself now.
Oh, get Dumpo Poseidon!
Gamba!
Dumpo!
It's the first roll you run into his surrounding foes, but
as they start to strike but bro, you can't pry me more.
I've already yeah, let's Like, you can't prime me more.
I'm already broken magic.
More prime.
Fuck it.
Wait, what?
I thought I got...
Oh, I was like, I didn't get double pot.
Yeah, I'm good, guys.
I lied.
Don't get Zeus.
It wasn't double.
Oh, no.
Not him again.
Oh, I hate this guy.
I don't know why, but there's just something about him that
fucks with me.
Oh, my God.
Like, I don't know.
There's just something about this guy that messes with me.
Like he just... I know he's not doing anything, but he's so
intimidating.
He's just standing there, but he's just so intimidating.
Alright, Russian cause is surrounding first, be struck by
lightning buffs.
Your chain deals more bad.
Oh, wait, we should get that too.
I'm gonna do chain lightning.
More damage.
Oh hey!
This should be...
My favorite man.
There he is.
Nicholas Cage.
He's centered on the self.
Become endured somehow to the incessant singing that always
echoes through these halls.
Speak not to me if echoes this or echoes that, okay?
Echo meant nothing to me and somehow got the wrong idea
anyway.
Narcissist.
And don't you get any ideas either.
Of course I remember his name.
I just didn't have to say it because he's in my heart, guys.
And he's in all our hearts, guys.
I don't have to say his name to know who he is.
Echo meant nothing to you.
I was talking about Skiller's song and how you've blocked it
out.
He's my hero.
I don't think I can't quite hear it now either.
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, yeah, we can't hear his song.
I learned to block you out with this.
With this.
Just in 100.
I feel like HP, right?
Increase your limit.
Yeah, I'm going to do...
Kitch kill.
Health limit.
Oh, yeah, one more!
I strive to be just like him.
He's my hero.
Love yourself.
You know what they say, guys?
Gotta remember that explodes.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck was that range?
Okay, I did not expect that fucking range.
Because you're usually not that fucking off.
All right Okay, let's get this guy out of here first nice
Yeah, money Honey, okay, we'll grab ash I don't think we
need more nectar more whiskers Here get these guys out of
here.
That's right.
You can't touch me.
I got the power of my uncle by my side yay nepotism Oh, I
don't like these guys the most because they just explode It
pisses me off All right, nice Oh god, there's some big boys
coming in some big boys
Yeah goodbye goodbye Wait I'm magic now how where did this
magic come from I'm broke they pride me so hard.
How the fuck did I get magic ability?
zero out of zero magic.
Not your current amount.
but an increase to your life limit.
Wait, what?
Oh, without restoring.
Okay.
Game plus seven now.
Might as well.
Have the money.
I'm gonna take this just for the quest.
Come on out.
Fuck it.
I'll take it for the quest.
Uh...
I mean, maybe I get another Should we, should we get the I
mean, there's a shop.
Or do you think I'm Too broke?
Am I too broke for the Shop, guys?
I can't tell Am I too broke?
Here it goes.
I'm gonna have a hundred and fifty.
I am not too broke.
Yay!
Oh, hey.
I'll grab this too.
I'm too broke for the hammer, though.
I don't understand why.
Oh, wait.
That's never mind um we'll get aphrodite yeah no hammer
though do we want to upgrade anything or just go straight
for aphrodite aphra i don't ever want to upgrade aphro it up
all right we'll aphro it up uh surrounding flick three week
and again once you stop Gain now for the rest of this life.
Three.
Yeah, more HP and magic.
But then it's like rushing, though.
Yeah, we'll grab that.
Yeah, oh my god, I'm so fucked.
Oh, guys, look.
Guys, Zira.
Guys, I get three magic.
We're rolling in it.
Oh my god.
Oh, shit.
Sorry, I skipped you.
His presence fills the underwater.
that much to me your auntie's back i let you have a week
break but i'm back three magic the possibilities are endless
that's right i'm here to engagement bait i feel like that's
all of twitter right now at least someone i saw someone chat
try to engagement bait me about some with xqc i'm I'm like,
I don't care.
I don't know.
I don't care what's going on.
I'm just fucking playing Hades, bro.
I don't know if they know this, but I've been at the dentist
the last week.
I've been dealing with two problems the last week.
All right, here.
Like, I don't know what the fuck is going on right now over
there.
I'm just playing Hades, bro.
No!
Oh god, oh god, okay, he wanted to hit me.
But how do I use my ability again?
Oh shit, okay.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Oh, nice.
No more beats for you.
That's right.
Your turn.
Oh, shit.
Oh, wait.
Sorry, I'm so fucking tanky.
Like, it doesn't matter.
That's just so tanky right now.
Oh, shit.
Okay, yeah, no problem.
We'll just grab her first.
Moon power!
I'll get rid of her first.
Because she's the easiest.
We'll get rid of drums last.
Oh, fuck.
It's okay.
It's only three.
You know, I can...
You know, fuck it.
Never mind.
I guess.
Wait, I can?
Unless...
It's like, bro, I barely keep up to date on Twitter.
I don't care.
I'm fighting.
I'm fucking fighting my... I care about this, though.
If they have Twitter, I'll be there spamming that shit.
Unless they have a Twitter.
I'm out coming for them.
I'm gonna make 20 accounts to send them 8 comics.
They can't block me.
There you go.
That's right.
I'm everywhere.
The Hater Grind mindset.
I'm creating 20 bot accounts.
And every time you ban one, another bot is created.
I'm the world's strongest hater.
My keepsakes manifest.
all right now now bring in the knuckle yeah i'll bring in
knuckle bones for the dog see i'm broke broke i have one
dollar to my name i have one dollar to my name to find my
ground guys not looking so well for the dokey Yoko Shima,
thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Hi, Doki, you've been really busy lately, and just now have
a little free hours, enjoy my Oshi!
Anyway, here's my feet money tax, what the fuck?
What do you mean by feet money?
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Affiliate, thank you for the file, gift the ships, thank
you, thank you.
Morning fields.
It's fine, as long as Aeris isn't here, I'm fine with that.
So how many times do I have to beat on my grandpa?
Okay.
okay this is i always forget where they oh wait i forgot to
talk here amid the overgrowth near to the like the what tax
okay i know for sure it's not 20.
who cling to shreds of love and hope that long since ceased
to be like 33 times it's rather bleak down here at least
five okay oh yeah back to mine this though
money all right what the why are you hiding in the grass
honey grass is not gonna save you from my me killing you but
i'm so tanky now the path you face uh we wanted this right
deals more damage whatever your hex has five plus 500 powers
the first time you know okay oh never mind no it because i
missed it Okay, I'll get rid of these guys first.
You want to send me to the shadow realm.
Moon power!
Nice.
More magic.
More ash.
I guess we get double money?
Wait, let's see if there's anything downstairs.
Just in case.
Also, it's not lagging, right?
The game?
Just want to be sure.
And name of the moon, she will punish you.
It's fine, that's good.
Okay, oh my god, 36...
I don't know how that feels.
I'm fucking rich, guys!
I have 36 magic now.
Oh my god, I haven't seen those numbers in so long.
That's crazy.
The money is actually blocking...
Blocking his death.
Uh...
Sider in the meter.
Okay.
I don't know.
Poseidon or...
We don't really have any Demeters.
Demi?
Alright.
I saw two.
Oh.
Okay.
I hate these guys so much.
To get rid of her kids first.
Their kids out of here.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
It's just three.
Oh god.
That's okay.
Get rid of the child.
There you go.
Just kill all your kids before I kill you.
So then you have to live with the fact that your children
are dead.
Killed all your kids, woman!
All your kids are dead now!
You outlived your child!
That's the worst, too.
Outliving your children?
That's right!
That's me!
That's fucking right.
I'll do it again.
I'll wait until you have another set of kids.
And I'll kill them too.
You think you could move on?
I'll get you.
Oh hey, infusion.
While you have at least six.
Whenever you would take at least 20 damage.
Take less.
I don't even have enough of this though.
Kina Bear that stops one instance of damage.
Do I get two or three?
Two?
I'm at five.
I have five right now.
I have five.
Three of you have six water.
Maybe I'll get another water.
Can you get more later?
Okay, take three.
Okay, I'll take three.
Oh, hey, Echo.
Wait, Echo's gonna be here.
Hello, girl.
Hey, Echo.
We missed you.
Narcissus and I were talking about you earlier.
Good things, of course.
Good things.
How have you been?
Oh, you know.
This place sure is a change for us, the honest.
If you've ever been.
Yeah, she didn't give me an extra demeanor.
Is that Narcissus?
Yeah, fuck that, yeah.
I'm only saying that's to get into her good grace, guys.
I don't mean that.
I love Narcissus.
as much as he loves himself which is almost impossible wait
your voice you know him oh no knowing all his suitors and
knowing you're here in the land of the brokenhearted
oh she broke her heart oh no there's one all right manifest
a copy oh here you go oh bro it's okay it's okay you're not
the only one you can only love himself oh another one your
spoon in the left most column gains levels spread across how
many you have wait is that good three what blessings and
increases oh that sounds really good three it is yeah i've
got a duo Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I just got plus four.
I was like, wait a minute.
That says plus four.
Oh, wait.
Hammer time.
Okay, I just noticed that.
That's a lot of pluses.
Okay, I don't have to, I shouldn't need to, uh, let's see.
I don't get another Echo, so I can get through this at many,
at whatever order I what okay but I need to get rid of you
Jesus Christ okay that's five that's five God there's so
many okay I forgot these guys said oh no no no no stop no
Suck!
Get away from me!
No!
Bad stuff.
Alright, boon time.
Yes, your tasks inflict freeze, repeal it.
Your attacks deal more damage.
Your surrounding flows.
I'll do attack.
Attack is always good.
Okay, money and then we'll get hammered last.
Jesus.
Wait, so you're not even part of this fight, bro.
Like, bro, nobody cares about you.
Nobody ever invites you to the parties.
You're not even part of this fight.
Jesus, that's so annoying.
Okay, this should be the last one.
Yeah.
Only to rest.
All right, nice.
Money.
All right, hammer.
Last one is the hammer.
We just need the...
cast where i can like send it out and then then we should be
good then we have a good build i really need the fucking
cast chucker jesus oh god they sent three of them in a row
too those ones are the worst the ones that just chuck the
fucking balloon things your special fires will have No, no,
you chat on to your special and deal.
Do I even have 30, right?
Or more attack, more attack.
You know, fuck it, more attack.
Superior might.
More attack means die fast.
If they have more attack, they can die faster.
Think about it.
That was crazy.
The math, it just adds up, you know?
adds up okay we'll go we'll go shop gone all this way my
lord yay okay we can have Olympus I accept this message oh
we can buy everything your special inflicts blitz that's my
right click rushing causes surrounding foes to be ah I don't
use enough magic I don't have enough magic for this One,
right?
Yeah.
And then we'll grab this.
Your chain lightning when you reclaim.
Oh, Gamba.
Grab the Gamba.
And then the armor.
That should be good.
Alright, let's go.
Two for more Gamba.
The Gamba will work eventually.
Been rolling around in miasma, have you?
Okay, he's gonna stop being angry soon.
right oh my god you bitch oh fuck I forgot how to I forgot
how to deal with that
god I hate are you fucking kidding me again okay oh my god
now it fucking oh god okay oh god okay that is bullshit oh
my god fucking course he saved up the worst ones as the
minions a fucking course all right we'll just beam it we can
just beam it all right this is five
he's not it's on the other side it's okay where did he go
all right here we go it's okay i'm on the other side of this
we should be safe what the fuck says when could he send that
I had the cast.
Okay, it's okay.
Explode some!
Okay, I should be safe from this.
Yeah, my tiny little hole, my safe hole.
Oh my god, okay.
It's fine.
He's almost dead anyway.
Moonbeam!
Oh my god, I can't moonbeam.
He would not let me moonbeam.
He's like, no touchy.
Yeah, the little saver.
Don't worry.
He's a good boy again.
Descends again into the comfort of his pit.
Alright, I fixed him.
I took him to the van.
Got him fixed.
No kids for him.
Yeah.
For now.
Oh my god, that took up half my HP.
That's like insane.
Alright, down I go.
Oh, I didn't see the little shiny thing.
It's such a tiny dot.
Fucking tiny ass dark.
He doesn't even see it.
So hard to tell.
Alright, we're gonna grab the tooth.
And then...
I still can't access this yet.
Is that what you...
Yes, Dad doesn't have balls.
You guys should know that by now.
Receive...
Okay, when do we take damage?
Let's grab that.
Because it's like $11 anyway.
So it's fine.
And that grabs a quest too.
Okay.
going down service entrance all right nice back to beat up
my grandpa the exposed inner workings of the infamously
interlocking chambers of the underworld are a mass of gold
tooth wheels a never-ending cycle turning at the Titan's
soul behest all right concentrate with all this racket
ever-shifting chambers Yay!
It's a lot.
I did it.
But...
It's predictable as the turning of the gears throughout this
place.
Alright.
It's fine.
It's pretty easy to kill.
As long as I have ice, these guys can't do shit.
And I gotta get rid of...
Gotta get out of here.
The only ones I'm scared of is definitely the time, guys.
Okay, I feel like...
like my normal attack does more damage than my moon beam.
I don't know.
I think I...
My beam is like so fucking... My moon beam in general is so
fucking weak as hell.
Because I did too much attack.
I boosted my regular attack so fucking much.
Oh no, not this.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm gonna make sure get this guy out of it.
Yeah, it's not Upgraded at all.
I haven't had a chance to upgrade it.
I never bumped into anyone to upgrade this
Okay, oh dad hey dad my other dad Greetings father.
Well, when will Cerberus let me pet him?
It's like a little tickle beam Quickly now tell me about
this Have you been?
Are you well?
I'm doing good.
I lost my arm But everything is cool All my life I didn't
have a childhood because you guys got kidnapped That's
alright Well, I'll have a childhood later, right?
So, I'll have to get back to you Depending on how it goes
It's cool, I didn't need a childhood I'm sorry Got to clean
up your mess, but it's cool
He's saying cool But I think it's not cool But this is all
that I can do for now But being locked up hearts for 1%
damage until you reach the limit and your Kronos take a
burst of damage.
Your dash strikes 1 or 3?
What?
I mean it's 30% oh, 30% attack and special damage.
It should be 1, right?
2 or 3 for the prophecy?
Does prophecy really matter?
They just give me like $5 and said have a good day and you
can buy like go buy ourselves a burger king meal from that
are you guys sure like five dollars is five dollars yeah
keep the change they don't give me anything to be fair two
i'll find i'll do three five he still doesn't want to give
me a pet.
Bad dog!
Can't believe it.
I understand.
Why does he not want to let me... Oh my god!
What the...
All guns.
Just all guns.
What the fuck was that?
Okay.
Whoa.
I don't know how I survived that.
That show is crazy.
Literally just...
How many guns do you want?
Alright.
Bye.
Okay, I'll get rid of.
Take away his armor first.
Okay, I'm a little bit afraid of gun, man.
Gun man, not...
Gun man does not make me feel joy.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, that's it.
Beam time.
Moon beam time.
My weak-ass tickle beam.
Sickle bean time Alright, nice Updated What did it give me?
Oh, the crawler I was hoping I would get another power up
area I guess not Fuck me, oh god Yeah, no, yeah, no, I don't
get anything I guess
Absolutely Yeah, no, just pure death That's fine Okay, I
want to get rid of guns Gun is the scariest The scariest one
Because gun moves really fast The bag gun
Okay I can freeze this though Yay Oh shit Pickle beam I will
grab this Oh I was hoping I find some more Money farmers but
I guess we go straight in Oh I'm Oh Oh, I'm so broke.
Oh, I could grab armor and Poseidon.
I guess we'll go with that.
Oh, when you sprint, you hit the first foe.
You run into a blast that knocks foes away.
Your cask gains power and knocks foes away.
Your move also launches.
Yeah, but I don't...
I guess one?
Because I don't use magic.
Yeah.
The will of water.
Oh, none of the Gamba worked.
Oh my god, look, look at my water.
Wee!
I'm spitting water out.
One way in.
Alright, grandpa time.
Got another grandpa killed in here.
I'm home.
Come closer.
Aides used some of his failing strength to spur you on.
Even whilst bound in chains, no god can break.
Your father yet proves to be a pest.
Yeah, but he's your son.
You raised him like that.
That's on you.
That means you're a fad.
I mean, he is definitely a very bad father.
He didn't finish the job.
The thing is, my girl, I can have both.
You should have seen the cruel, inventive ways your father
tortured mortal souls.
Thus, I dispense a form of justice to him.
Yeah, but, like, those souls were bad people, though.
So they deserve this.
Is it really bad if I torture bad people?
Oh shit, nice.
Oh fuck, okay, I'm fine, I'm fine, I'm fine.
Oh god, oh my god, that was scary.
Oh no, not Toho, not Toho, not Toho, not Toho, no Toho.
It's fine.
We're okay.
It's okay, we're still here.
okay what oh bump it's okay we're still we're still we're so
healthy and where did he go oh my god another one another
time stop bro how many time stops do you want are you
serious okay that should have been are you okay it's okay oh
my beam oh my god freeze oh i missed the freeze but that's
okay
Nice, it's okay.
No moon beam for you.
Oh, ho ho ho ho.
Okay.
I got him.
Don't.
Maybe.
Maybe I don't got him.
Oh, shit!
I did not get him.
Oh my god, I forgot this move.
Oh my god, I keep forgetting his...
God!
I'm taking everything.
It's okay, I'm such a... I'm a goddamn tank, so it doesn't
matter.
I'm a tank anyway.
Yeah, that's me.
Two, one.
It's okay, I'm also a tank.
Goodness.
Oh, fuck, I keep...
I keep forgetting.
I keep forgetting he I'm like he hits back I don't know why
I keep forgetting that I'm like oh my god guys he hits back
guys who would have thought
Oh my god it's crazy
Oh are you serious this is not fair
This is not fair What the fuck am I supposed to kill that?
It's okay.
Alright.
He dodged!
Oh no.
I made it.
Are you fucking- it's okay, I still have two death defiance.
Guys, I'm only pretending to like get hit by everything.
Guys, it's okay.
I have two death defiance.
I'm only pretending to get hit.
Yeah, plus one!
Yeah, I'm creating tension in an artificial way.
Don't need no death defiance.
Let's go!
22 minutes is that my fastest run i don't even know this one
was me like being confused too because i don't remember how
to play i don't even know what my record is all right no i
can't just put him in my pocket vanquished only for the
moment scheming chronos cannot be so easily destroyed yet in
her every fleeting victory against him fear this one was 22
minutes something she thought lost i still remember flashes
of this place yeah no i got a good-eyed spiel for this all
right all right time to talk to my brother again see if you
got anything done impressive you won that while holding a
cell phone of the captive underworld prince.
An ordinary mirror.
Nothing more.
To the abyss of the subconscious.
Down I go.
I'm gonna eat my bagel.
It worked.
Oh, wait, shit.
I forgot the move.
I thought that would be autopilot.
I forgot.
There's no autopilot for this.
I can only have autopilot when I start talking to them.
She looks a bit like mother, doesn't she?
Which means...
Oh, blast.
I never thought...
I look just like him, then.
Yeah, that's right.
I got mom's good looks.
Hi there, Malinui.
My investigation into our grandfather's scheme has begun.
Though difficult to make good progress without telling
anybody what I'm up to.
Don't take this the wrong way, but this truly is your only
idea.
Yes, I don't think I can stop Kronos here even Olympus is
stuck trying to keep your whole life and you're just fucking
parted off your brother What fucking plan is that?
That's the one thing I'm like this is a shitty plan She grew
up she trained her whole life just to be like you handle it
That's our family for you father certainly has no love for
Kronos, but he never speaks of him I happen to know what
went over between them to have made things this bad.
You're in a better position to ask our father about that
than I am.
Kronos was a tyrant and his children wouldn't have it.
The Fates themselves deemed that the gods should rule.
But that apparently wasn't enough for him.
Oh, that's why he's punishing the Fates.
She's like, how dare you?
So now you want me to stop.
I've had mixed experiences vanquishing certain members of
our family before, but that wasn't forever.
And you've said next to nothing about how you expect.
me to do it look i have knowledge of an incantation known as
dissolution of time it requires several complicated steps i
shall explain along the way if it works it should unravel
him
unravel him that's a little vague for me unless kronos turns
out to be a spool of yarn can you be more specific unmake
him destroy his ambitions along with him undo all the harm
he caused a Three-fold family bond is required.
You, me, and Kronos.
Then we shall infuse a special weapon with an emotion of his
own being.
Okay, so the magic spell requires him.
That's right.
What about your dad?
I mean, your dad is still here.
Why does that have to be like...
Okay, oh, and then we infuse it with a special weapon.
But it's a weapon for my brother or like for me?
Because we could just get my dad in here.
Our dad.
though i'll admit i don't like having to kill our family
members just because father doesn't know how to get along
with them yeah like does it have to be me does it have to be
like who has the weapon why can't i turn my dad into the
weapon the last kronos is starting to revive i have to go
because my dad is related and remember this is for all of us
i will and i understand i think we didn't ask to be born
into this but it's what we got we'll handle it as best we
can Let's break the chains for it.
That's right.
Thank you, brother.
Take care of yourself.
And be kind to mother, father, Cerberus, and all for me.
Hades isn't strong enough.
Bro, Hades is like a fucking god.
We're half, we're like, and we're gods too, I guess.
But still.
To hell and back.
The heavens next.
We did it.
Can you believe it, little one?
I did it.
I got him.
Again.
Yeah, I mean, I guess he is out of shape.
Oh, hey, she's here.
Oh, hello there, my friend.
I happen to see the boatman sculling down the Kakaitas,
presumably to you.
For he had all sorts of supplies.
He was generous enough to offer me passage.
Whether he knew it or not.
Oh, yeah.
Hades fell off, guys.
That sucks.
Oh, yeah, I forgot.
I should eat my antibiotics now.
That's why I didn't eat it yet.
Because I didn't...
like maybe one or two more runs before i have to go all
right yeah we're free she always makes me pay i'm certain
cissy wants to bang the spider is there anything we can do
to make your stay with us more comfortable i would
technically don't need to take pillion killers but just to
be safe especially since the boatman is my ticket home i'll
just make certain all my silk here is patched up and then be
on my way be well won't you she has pretty privilege not
fair he gets to go on the boat for free you too princess if
i may princess the faded list of minor prophecies have you
been able to make use of it i have thank you for bringing it
to me so then the fates already know what's going to happen
in all this everything i'm going to do well yes and no the
faded list says as little of your future is necessary I
briefly was its host myself and saw there but a single
prophecy that I would pass it on to you then that's a
prophecy fulfilled yeah we did it whatever ails you your
companion shall listen oh she's singing hey the sonorous
voice of the goddess of the hunt fills the clearing like a
ray of moonlight Sturring the eternal souls of shades that
there reside Show me and do something real quick gameplay
What is it display?
Oh, it doesn't have that.
Okay, I was thinking like if it has the thing where if I tab
out like the music would still play But they don't have that
option.
Ah, that sucks That's just it.
This is why they didn't win our game of thee don't forget
what we decided here is that borderless i thought i was
already borderless we are worried at the threshold to this
little clearing yes though don't you ever slip catch your
mind drifting back to your concerns that's what the song is
for it doesn't make our troubles go away it's so we can face
them as best we can oh wait that's what borderless is i
thought it was already borderless what the am i at if it's
not phone screen what the fuck am i at then yeah no it's not
borderless guys it's it's not borderless i just want to
check my mess my dms real quick yeah uh okay was that give
me a sec i gotta work message real quick i
Why is everyone...
It's about the May Cafe stuff.
They're like, remember to do this.
You remember to do that.
And I'm like, I guess.
I guess.
I guess I'll remember.
Oh, yeah.
So, we just found out.
If you are, if you are coming to the maid cafe thing, you're
coming to the maid cafe today and tomorrow, men and I are
both singing different songs for both days.
So there's like, if you come on Friday, it tastes Friday,
right?
Friday, we're gonna sing in two songs.
Like we have two songs each.
And then Saturday, it'll be a different song from what we
chose on Friday.
So y'all get a unique experience because we're like asking
about, We were asking about if we could sing different songs
instead of like what we assigned Like earlier and they're
like, yeah, you can sing a different song But all right Join
i got used to bathroom so i'm joining in too sing with it
gotta pee stranded out
to find your refuge here
the silver sisters wait
home till night in shadow
take shelter
in the one sheltered by the dark the silver sister's way
marks her passage silently watching with the eye of night
above us all hiding in plain
I'm back.
Oh, yes, right.
So no more singing.
all right let me uh all right we do one i think i could do i
could sneak like i just sneak like one i can sneak two more
runs into this good boy i know what to do a necromantic
necromantic influence getting the ability to sprint into
loony shades you encounter turn them against your foes wait
how do i turn them how do i do that jesus oh wait my psyche
is nine i was like oh my god why do i have I realize it's
just my sanity.
So they contain an infernal trove.
I guess I'll grab that.
Yeah, I was going to say, I like money.
Oh my god, the fucking street.
Okay, that reminds me the Street Fighter celebrity fucking
interview thing where the guy grabbed the mic was like,
we're only here for the money.
And I'm like, okay, bro, okay.
I can say that because it's funny.
You can't say that because...
You can't say that because, like, who the fuck are you?
Like, like, who the fuck are you, bro?
Yeah, you can't say that because it's real.
You tell that they wanted to cut his mic, too, afterwards.
Like, they were like, you're not supposed to, that is off
script, buddy.
Someone, like, I'm pretty sure they're like, bro, that had
to be off script.
Yeah, on stage in front of a million, two million people
were watching it on YouTube and Twitch.
Tiny grain, a key of sorts, to the dissolution of time.
Do you concur?
I do.
That very incantation sprang to mind.
An expression of all you taught me of his weakness.
He's a comedian.
is like I think of mature 90% people that are watching this
did not know who he was so they thought it was real tis
merely evidence that our concerted efforts have not been in
vain you cross the underworld like I didn't know who the
fuck that guy was I remain in shadows but we'll get him head
mistress away the fourth time's a charm I got more psyche
yeah how did you come here to gloat huh i beat yeah that's
right i'll beat him three times still alive you realize
don't you yeah what you've done huh all you did was mo i
wasn't coming here to gloat and mom is still in prison this
is still a step if i could vanquish kronos once i can do it
again and one of these nights he's not going to come back
yeah because one of these
sure if you leave the first part oh yeah but you haven't
even left the first world yet for your goddess on behalf of
all the shades residing here we are honored to be in your
service and stand ready to do whatever it takes to prevail
please share these spoils with whom maybe you see fit some
nectar thank you yeah the gods of olympus right now you
truly won't mind if I pass these bottles along.
Okay.
I mean, I could try a surface.
What do I need?
What materials do I need for the surface?
Or saw the life-draining car set brood.
Oh, here, this one.
So I need thalamus.
Oh, that's the one I'm growing.
And then two, one more moss and two nightshades.
Wait, I have zero nightshades.
I mean, I'm growing that right now.
I'm growing a thalamus.
right now.
Malamus is with Chaos.
So, like...
What now?
I could do one more...
I'll do one more downstairs run and then one upstairs run
for the moss.
Because I just need one moss.
Yeah.
I should be able to increase my grass.
Okay, I can do two more.
A 9% chance to deal...
Wait, what?
Oh, wait, I need...
How much psyche do I need?
Oh, my God.
Okay, I got Ordemur's psyche, guys.
Sorry.
My mind is... Oh, hey!
Hey, boatman!
You picked a fine time to make your deliveries, my lord.
That's Artemis singing nearby.
Although perhaps such music isn't your taste.
Yeah, he looks like a heavy metal guy.
All right, let's grab some psyche again.
Uh...
Now we wait.
I'll grab some psyche.
Wait, why do I need fate fabric?
Oh, we'll grab some.
How many fate fabrics do I need?
the fuck why don't you use fate fabric just like oh this oh
i don't need that though i don't need shadow extraction yeah
but i don't really need it i guess this oh wait uh reveal
golden urns which yields i mean i guess i could grab that
now whatever gleams with gold shall soon be found so might
it be okay i'll grab that And then I'll grab I'll grab more
psyche right now That's right I don't think I can afford
Wait can I
Yeah I don't I can't Wait okay I just gotta be sure I was
like My math is bad Maybe I miscalculated No no Definitely
Definitely cannot get that in I was like Oh but maybe I just
miscalculated I'm let's grab that just because i can't
afford it oh wait ash and wool where the fuck am i gonna
find wool oh i guess like on the surface i guess okay we'll
grab when did i grab last the purse grab the purse okay now
i can do oh wait i should be able to upgrade now the black
coat there's more weapons What the fuck is adamant?
Oh, that's what the fabric is for.
Trade for it.
Oh, oh my god, I could have bought more fabric.
Hey, by the way, I meant to say nice going on occasion of
achieving your objective and all that.
Okay, so we can't afford another weapon yet because I'm
gonna get adamant, so I'm just gonna breeze through it.
I don't think I need, I don't think I need to do quests yet.
I was able to defeat him.
Yes, commander.
Yep, but my ultimate objective is far from complete.
i'm just gonna go through it without any of the uh any of
the restrictions soon as one's complete along comes another
so i can grab the materials fast by your leave yeah but then
like i also have to what the oh i can oh that's so cool i
like that i can kidnap them a secret's a monument tonight
yeah but then if i Alright, I go downstairs, because I need
to farm the materials downstairs too.
You're that?
Oh, wait, the adamant is upstairs?
Fuck, okay.
Well, I'm gonna grab the, I'm gonna grab the seed thing.
I'll go grab the, the chrono seed, whatever, because I need
one more.
I need one more chrono seed, and I'll do the surface,
because surface is, like, really fast.
I gotta get this one over with, first.
I'll grab this one over with first before I go to surface.
Oh, hey!
Oh, and Kronos?
Wait, have I...
Have I gifted HEP anything yet?
Watch as it must be nice flattening him.
Starting to wonder what's the plan here besides that.
Your cat tasking cause.
Oh, wait, I like that.
Which is better?
One or two?
I mean, both of them...
Okay.
Okay, I'll give HEP later.
I don't know.
I've never done one before.
I've done two, but I've never done one.
Oh shit.
Okay, that shit's strong.
I think if I do the cooldown thing, it'd be like even
stronger.
All right.
So early, early Kronos.
Okay, I'll give to, I'll give Kronos something.
If you'll permit me almighty chaos, I wish you to have this
gift of nectar in accordance with my family's custom among
relatives and friends.
None of this would have been possible if not for you.
I'll give I'll let I'll give you permission to give me more
free stuff
yeah I got an embryo holy fuck whose embryo is this
yeah guys I'm giving you the privilege to give me free
Things?
What an honor.
Your son.
Your specialist deal.
Any gold.
Oh, you lose.
Okay.
Toss and earn for an okay VTuber.
I would get a lot of gold.
Yeah, I was thinking about that.
Like, I'll get a lot of money.
Oh, wait.
I should grab this, too.
Within the silence of the infinite abyss, lies infinite
possibility.
The limitless and unseen building blocks of all that has
ever been conceived.
What?
It's really quite a lot.
Nice, I dug out some gold.
Wait, did I see...
Uh, we'll grab ash.
Or not ash.
What is it called?
I don't even remember what those are called.
Jesus Christ I gotta make sure I don't fucking are you
fucking okay I got Jesus Christ okay this is actually I just
gotta be sure I'm not in the fucking vicinity uh oh I could
fish tool tool required no grab heart bones oh is there
bones okay jesus okay so it is ranged too so wherever i'll
go wherever i'll go it'll also be there too all right hard
time uh ash silk cocoons silk cocoons what the fuck this is
new oh my god oh that's her food sorry sorry for stealing
your food real quick but like I can't progress don't worry
I'll grab you dinner next time there it is oh of course it's
the last one don't worry Arachne I swear I owe you a dinner
I literally got rid of her entire fucking food supply this
was her food for the winter
oops oops Hey, I don't suppose you happen to see a woodsy
goddess stalking through.
Greenish attire, wielding a bow about her height.
Yeah, I'm looking for my cousin.
I know which one you mean, my friend.
And I know she's been nosing about.
Okay, I owe you one big dinner, even though I ruined your
entire supply for the winter.
You know, you know, gods gotta be like gods.
You know, boys.
Boys like, gotta be like boys.
You make it sound as though you fear Olympus more than you
fear Kronos and so.
Oh, I do.
It's not Kronos that made me- They're not gifted already?
I've grown more used to it with time.
Now go find your woodsy goddess and be careful not to lead
her here, alright?
I thought I already gifted her stuff.
Dawn plus 20 and I mixed your cast deal 100 damage.
Yep, but mixed your story whenever you- Dawn, the grand
suit, whenever- Okay, yeah, I'm gonna get the fucking 100.
Hope I live long enough for this.
Am I a gift or another gift?
Each time I pass through Erebus, it's comforting to know I
may run into you along the way.
Here's something for your lovely lair.
Oh, why this is very sweet.
It should attract a host of flies.
See, look, I gives her a dinner.
Very, very much.
See?
She's fine now.
It's only fair.
Look at that.
I replenished her dinner.
It's all it took.
Oh, yeah.
Join me.
All right.
I almost almost got me there.
Aphrodite or shop?
Uh, we'll go Aphrodite and then we'll go, because there's
always a shop at the end anyway, right?
Oh god, it's fine.
Okay, wait, actually?
No, wait.
That's my entire... I forgot.
I have armor.
I forgot about my armor situation.
Alright, this is fine.
Oh, fuck.
It's okay.
I still have six armor.
Oh, my god.
Alright, goodbye.
It was nice.
You know, it was a nice run.
It was a nice run.
I had it for one location.
Isn't that cool?
Such rage must have felt.
to not end me as much whatever innate satisfaction there may
be in beating up that nasty old titan is there a grander
plan in all of this for what we're going to do let's see
your special deals more damage to nearby foes, rushing
damages, gain now, wait I should grab that now, grab me
three fuck it that would be tanky
oh hey, money money
All right, that's good.
I don't have to worry about the explosions now.
I think if I could set my cooldown for the attack, it would
be like, I would have like the perfect build.
Let's see.
Oh, God, collect reward.
God, it's just one thing.
Your next duration, you move down.
It's $10.
$10 is $10.
Fuck it.
I'll grab it.
Like, I'm so fucking rich.
$10 is nothing right now to me.
In game.
I'm not trying to say anything here.
Just so you guys know.
I'm for the people, guys.
I'm for the people.
I have to clear up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just so you guys know, in-game.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my god.
Wait, there's a lot of shit going on here.
Nice.
Get in there.
It started!
Oh, shit!
Okay, just tank the entire missile.
It's okay.
It's only five.
I have damage.
Oh.
And then we dig through this.
And what did that give me?
Oh, Ash.
Okay.
Grab heart.
It was always good.
I'm so rich right now.
I don't really need.
Stop.
I feel like I don't really need anything.
End game.
before the people in so i need i need hp more i need more hp
yeah just so you guys know
all right nice yes i pay i pay taxes just like you guys
oh i'm gonna go for the shop it's because I just have so
much money to spend anyway.
Yeah, see, I knew it.
Keep getting shipments of those gold and Kronos coins.
I melt them down and dump the goop into the earth whence it
came.
So Kronos can make more.
I should really get insurance.
I should really get health insurance.
And dental insurance.
And all the other type of insurances.
Here he has deals.
Damage three times in successions to foes in the blinding
circle.
abiding circles okay um your foe is near after you can cause
a blast that deals your your weapon deals more damage based
on okay i don't have any of that um three is good and buy
armor but then like i need a uh you don't have any insurance
well the thing is i'm self-employed and by being
self-employed i have to insure myself
But, I don't have the armor regen, though.
If I lose, guys, I lose my armor really quick, though.
That's the only issue.
I lose my armor really quick.
I'm definitely getting dental insurance, though, after the
incident.
Yeah, I'm currently out of the system.
Out of the Canadian healthcare system.
Okay, I'll try, I'll try.
I'll try my best.
Oh, I only have, like, one boon I didn't realize.
Moros returned.
He's joined us at the crossroads.
Now we've no fewer than three mighty sons of Knicks within
our ranks.
Granted, one's always faster.
But yet, my tax is still paid for the health insurance that
I'm not allowed to get.
That's the crazy part.
I'm paid for other people's health care.
Here goes I gotta fix that How fast the task I've told my
brother of what Kroners has done But he expressed reluctance
I'm my own black company I'm canceling a company doesn't
provide Ensure health insurance or dental insurance Stokey
Oh my god you gotta spice to the CEO about this
That's crazy A complication.
Tokey versus Tokey.
Especially from your father.
We gotta cancel him.
With doubt.
We have no recourse here, Millennial.
They don't even have Tesla.
For naught.
He also asked me what exactly happened between Kronos and my
father.
Yeah, don't you care about Tokey's health, Tokey?
Does anyone?
This war he's waiting.
Don't even have to.
Bad insurance.
Why would you still work for that company, dokey?
Leave your own company.
Every choice history is of no bearing to our present state.
In war, one would be wise to not give undue credit to one's
enemies.
If you spend all your time so deep in thought, then you
shall hesitate to act.
And your moment shall pass.
Bro, you know what's even...
You know what's so fucked up?
Doki?
The company keeps like 100% of the profits.
Like that's so...
That is so messed up, guys.
The situation is crazy.
Okay, there you go.
Damn, that's the leak.
That's rough, bro.
I know.
So messed up.
Oh, my God.
I ran into it.
I was like, you didn't hit me.
And I felt bad.
There you go.
No.
Oh, my God.
I got hit at the last second, too.
That's the worst part.
I actually got hit on the...
Are you fucking...
Oh, kid.
Oh.
Oh, my army!
Ah, my army!
Ah!
Okay, we gotta get armor regen.
Okay, we definitely need to get armor regen here.
God damn, I used it on the fucking the witches.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
There you go.
Oh!
Doki gets all the profits, but Doki just gets paid in.
Oh shit.
At least I got an achievement, yeah.
Yeah, but Doki got an achievement just now.
Yay, good stuff.
Beneath the outer edge of Erebus extends a hidden region of
the underworld, known only to few, and navigable only by
fewer still.
That's crazy that my grandpa said hasn't found this place
yet just burn the forest down like it's not that hard what's
that one do uh what's this game plus one each well uh uh get
random oh wait i should grab this okay but i want to get the
boon thing though
oh grab i feel like we'll grab this i feel like that's
better and then we're still up to 50 hp i don't have any hp
yeah armor is big your tax and special deals 200 well now
i'm powered your cast deals 30 35 fuck it i mean i have the
money for it might as well buy it down i go yeah i'm gonna i
already get the boon the i already get the boon power
potential for it and then i'll and then i'll get the armor
next actually No, I should always go for it.
That's right.
Fight for me!
You're already in hell anyway.
You're already dead.
You might as well.
That's right, go!
Okay, this build, my current build really sucks right now.
I'm so weak.
I'm not really fat on my current build.
Yeah, we'll grab that.
Oh, wait, nice.
I just don't have, I think it's because I don't have any
boons at all.
That's why it sucks.
I don't have any really good boons.
Other than my hat, like the hefty sting.
Yeah, I'm just gonna lock you in real quick.
Alright, hammer time.
You attack does 50%.
Oh, wait.
Um, plus 50% damage or three?
Okay.
Two?
It also does.
But it's hold.
Oh, but it's hold.
Yeah, but I don't hold.
I'm going to do plus third.
I just realized it's cast.
Yeah.
I don't cast it.
I'm going to do three.
I barely.
I barely cast it.
My silver shines.
I just go.
I just go pop, pop, pop.
I don't hold it.
I barely hold it.
Oh, mighty chaos.
Oh, he doesn't want to talk to me anymore.
5.1 for your actors, you use 50%.
You have not clearing two out count for you.
You have 75% chance to find 100% resources with your
gathering tools for the next encounter.
4.
You should send 3?
You say I can beat it in time?
I'll try.
Okay, I'm actually...
Okay, we'll grab this real fast.
Oh my god, it's a boss fight.
first okay um oh my god okay okay okay okay this is really
oh my god this is so bad this is so bad a fucking curse it's
a rat a fucking curse a fucking curse it's a rat oh my god
i'm not okay oh my god i'm not okay guys i'm i'm not okay
i'm not okay it's not good this is not good i'm not I'm not
like built for this for this area
It's so bad I'm so bad with a rat I'm so bad with a rat I'm
so bad with this guy Okay He's almost dead He's almost dead
Okay there you go That's okay it's okay I lost half my HP
but it's okay Oh it's God God's what a monster He's so scary
He's so scary to be the rat not like any of the rest of us
were able to as you can plainly see he is the hardest boss
he's so tiny and does so much okay your sprint leaves when
your attack or special deal damage restore oh magic okay we
we could do the mat you do there are nowhere near other foes
okay we should get snuff candles for the for the boss fights
i'm gonna do snuff candle for the boss oh oh okay Oh, okay.
Did he just...
Oh, okay.
I didn't have a choice, but I'll take it.
Yay!
I got both!
Jesus Christ.
Okay, that's a lot of...
That's a lot of damage.
I don't even know what's going on anymore.
I don't even...
It was just a lot of...
That's a lot of damage.
What the fuck is going on?
Okay.
Nice.
The foes eliminated.
Did I grab?
Did I do it?
The keep safe effect has spied.
Let's see.
The witch strike.
Any money you gain.
I did it, right?
Yeah!
What did I even... What did I get doubled on?
This one?
Okay, I have magic and...
I technically can do a magic build now.
I'll grab ash.
Okay, that's done what the fuck is she still oh my god oh my
god i i don't like my build at all i will say my build is
pretty ass i think i gotta make sure i don't oh nice i did
it i leave now goodbye
There should be a...
No farming thing?
Huh?
There was a forget-me-not here.
I swear it was a forget-me-not.
Is that wrong?
We'll grab more ash.
Don't look down.
Yeah, I don't...
I don't know.
It does not feel like...
Oh, fuck!
I feel like my damage is so low, too.
That's the thing.
I feel like I'm not doing that much damage.
I need more boons.
But I'm not getting any boons.
At all.
Yeah, I'm not getting anything.
We'll grab this.
Oh, okay.
Well, I have enough for Hestia.
If your attacks end special, gain power, the more...
Oh, I have three right now.
Should I grab Infusion?
Or one?
I have three Fire Boons.
One?
One is better?
One for Boss.
Oh, I thought you said F is good.
You had more porn into it.
I'm like, excuse me?
But you said, um, I was like, excuse me, what did you say?
Whoa.
She would never have to give up anything to use my power,
little star.
But if a handful of wilds misreads, you even more reliably,
then so be it.
All right, let's see.
Your hex five is a beam that deals 500.
Oh, yeah, no, we'll get the healer.
one.
The heal one's always good.
Yay, heal time.
Yay, moon water.
Oh, wait, I can literally use it right now.
Yay, I'm healed.
My 15 HP.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
Why did I forget?
I can't suck.
I forgot.
I was trying to get my cough drop, but then I remembered
that I'm not allowed to suck on candy.
As me.
Your haters back.
That's right.
I've created my 70th account.
I'm going to cancel another concert.
Perhaps you shall be hunted by some other agent, though.
Your fans are going to make you keep providing full refunds
so you'll earn nothing.
The auntie is back.
And she's going to put in a good word for us, won't she?
Boom!
Okay.
All right, nice.
All right.
Boom!
That's right!
Drummer, God!
Get your guitarist next!
You know what?
Heal!
That's all right.
That's right, you're next!
Oh fuck, that's okay.
I already healed anyway.
It's okay.
Oh my god, I hit just in time.
There's the kit.
Oh shit!
Wait, that's not fair.
This is a three against one.
Sorry, I'll get rid of the drummer.
Drummer boy.
What?
hits me?
That's bullshit.
Boom!
You're gonna fuck this.
Getting that 15 HP.
I mean, he's almost dead.
There you go.
That's right.
And again!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
It's fine.
I'll just burn her a little.
Because water's weak against fire, right?
Guys, that's how it goes.
Time to eat some clam.
I actually don't like clam.
I'm not a...
Oh, see, I hate it.
Look at that.
I'm justified for being an anti.
It's justifiable.
Alright.
Then we get the guardian.
And then we have a pattern going in.
Can I gain a random item?
Wait, gain plus two?
What's this?
Mystery seeds?
Oh, we need that.
I mean, we have the money for this.
We'll grab this and this.
I get Witch's Mark?
What the fuck is a Witch's Mark?
Oh!
My cast!
Oh, six encounters.
Never mind.
Doki, she's just trying to follow her dreams.
Stop being a hater.
Simple mind.
I think it was super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Well, sometimes, some people's dreams don't come true.
You think I didn't have dreams?
If my dreams can't come true, her dreams can't come true.
That's fucking right.
Nobody's dreams are coming true today.
It's true.
If I can't have it, no one can.
I want to like...
What's the other item?
Oh, it's...
armor.
I mean, it doesn't matter here, I'm just gonna grab it just
in case.
Just for the sake of it.
That's fucking right.
Burn!
Okay, so it was a POM and what else.
Just get these guys out.
POM and Moon.
I already have a double for POM.
Come on out.
Okay.
Oh, God, it's a wolf.
Oh, God, the wolf is scary, though.
I will admit, wolf is scary.
Wolf does a lot.
Oh, my God.
Just as I said that, he fucking jumped me.
All right, let's get upgrades.
We need this.
Hex restores 10.
There you go.
Oh, whoops.
Went into the slow accidentally.
Alright, yeah, it's just one left.
Because I got everything else already.
Boom!
Burn!
Okay, nice.
Oh, you're cast and flicked.
I feel like I should just put it on my strike, right?
Just to keep investing on the attack one.
I feel like...
Just to make it more worth it.
Okay, get this guy out.
Okay, the meter.
We'll grab all of this.
This has everything.
I'm sorry, the meter.
You have, it's just one the meter.
We'll go this way.
Okay, we'll get this guy out of here.
Boom!
Oh, that's it?
Hammer should be the repeat.
Yeah, if Hammer lasts...
Okay.
God.
Beat the Medusa so much.
Jesus!
Okay, it didn't hit me.
I dodged it because I'm just good like that.
Getting this.
Bomb time.
And...
Oh.
One or three, chat.
One or three.
What?
Smolder?
Okay.
We'll grab with Smolder.
Oh no, I have one armor.
That's right.
1% upgrade damage.
Shit.
Got the ash.
Is there a tree anywhere?
Tree doko?
Wait, what?
Are you gonna kill still me?
I could be standing there on guard duty right now.
Yeah?
Oh my god, he's got...
She's gonna kill us.
No!
Are you fucking...
She kills us all!
She's actually...
She's actually following me!
Oh, that bitch!
She's actually following...
Oh my god!
You're so rude!
You're actually a bitch!
There's no way...
She's actually following me!
Body blocking me, dude.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Wait, did she win?
Did she win?
Oh, my God.
Wait, did she...
I don't even know.
Oh, my God.
Only one by two.
Okay, thank God.
Okay, I got...
Oh, thank God.
At least she didn't steal the hammer, guys.
At least... Bro, she's...
She's such a fucking hater.
She actually...
waited i was so confused i was like oh is she not gonna
fucking do an attack is she fucking waited for me that
where's the tree oh there it is golden once again okay it's
just one last one i just want to be sure actual hater she's
my auntie that's my auntie right there
Okay, there she is.
Okay, your attack has more range and deals 100% damage.
Your attack hits...
Oh, that's good.
Your attack hits two times.
Yeah, I'm grabbing that.
The two times attack.
Think I can finally go.
Oh, hey, Narcissus.
Oh, wait, Echo.
I get Echo again.
And I can get another hammer.
this I wish I knew what you were doing in a place like this
though you can't just tell me can you your heart must have
been broken oh by nice oh my god you fell in love a
narcissist of all people broken heartbroken bro you're yeah
no like that's on you you should expect that
get this i don't get to have another hammer after your next
purchase from okay yeah i have to do the palm palm palm he's
so handsome oh my god two okay no this is okay this okay
that's not even random at that point upon me oh my god i
literally oh wait oops i got too excited
Nice.
I got too excited with that.
Yeah, my attack.
Now it's, now I'm strong as fuck.
Wait, which one do I get?
Left or right?
This has a, that's, this has Hermes and that's Apollo,
right?
Apollo and then this only has Hestia.
Hermes, right?
Hermes is either jack shit or really good.
Yeah.
That's the thing.
Hermes is like, So RNG.
Is that really fucking good or like dog shit as hell?
The two seconds is fucking crazy.
And I have double hit too.
I actually have like a crazy ass build.
I have infinite magic.
Grab Hermes first.
Jesus.
Yeah, no.
Oh my god.
This is so fucking strong.
insane how strong this is yeah i know and i've technically
infinite magic
like click click click click if it's one i want to make it
to one second at least okay ending gain is worth more
receive plus 100 gain a dodge chance the move that increases
the more boons you have most foes range shots are slower
yeah i'm gonna do a hard money.
I legit, I don't guys, it's okay.
I don't think I need more money.
I there's I think I'm I oh my god and I have so much like I
don't even technically I don't even need more magic too like
legitimately I think like I have enough magic because I have
magic regen
yeah oh god wait what hit me Forget me.
I was not paying attention.
Yeah, my Chaos Boon has like insane money gain too.
Like it.
Let's just be full HP.
Just because I can.
Just for the sake of it.
Oh shit, okay.
Oh my.
So many things on my screen right now.
There you go.
Get her out of the way.
Nice.
God, I'm so strong.
Who are you?
What did you do with my gamioshi?
End game.
At least for a while.
You were doing, wasn't it?
Fine work.
No, I'm not at heart.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm for the people.
Your sprint is faster.
Your attack has a chance.
Wait.
Does that mean I can hit four times?
Oh, shit.
Wait, this is good.
It's faster.
Oh, but I can have days, though.
Wait, I can have four hits.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Two or three.
Also, Broken Bomb.
Thank you.
Super Chat.
Where's my Oshi Aeros at, Doki?
Where is Best Girl?
Ares.
Don't worry about it.
They got her.
Oh, 5% is not 20, right?
What's up with the tomato salad?
What do you mean they got it?
Yeah, they got it.
Yeah, we're not gambling here.
Oh my god, I'm so fast.
I don't remember what the second...
Oh, it was days.
Okay.
We'll go to the shop.
We have so much to spend.
Oh, hey.
Dig this, huh?
Some seeds.
Oh, more seeds.
I might as well.
Cardio gain.
Oh, my God.
I'm even faster.
Your attacks are special.
Gain more your attacks inflict scorch.
What is the replace?
You need a chance to dodge, which is double against scorch
afflicted foes.
Three, right?
I should grab three.
So I can infuse something.
I just double check.
Right here.
Yeah!
Saberus, it's me.
It's me.
Don't you remember it?
And he's like, I kill!
Yeah, yeah, it definitely looks like he remembers.
Oh, good.
God, are you fucking kidding me?
Oh, fucking course!
The shadow man is here.
Oh, now he sends these guys.
Okay.
Bye.
I have heels, though.
I think we forgot.
Remember when I had that special armor, or what?
That special armor.
Buff sure is helping me, alright?
Never seen a single armor since guys what does armor even
look like anymore no it heals jesus christ if i had the
armor build it would be even faster the dreaded hound of
hell assumes again a shape so sinister as scared that's a
fast ass i think i have a really insane build right now yeah
be sued yeah i'm going gotta go fast you're looking better
already tucked away yeah nice having quelled the fury of the
fearsome triple-headed monster Cerberus the princess of the
dead stands poised to delve into the pits of Tartarus where
weights her life yeah my grandpa families are hard salute
you there you're from Elysium he's like that's me That's
right.
It's a red shade.
Who's a red shade?
Could switch my keepsake.
All right, we'll get the teeth now.
Just in case.
Keen plus 10 now.
Ensure a KS spawns.
It costs $0 to enter.
I can't afford all of this.
Yeah.
Oh, I keep forgetting I don't have access to this.
Oh, that's not...
Oh!
Oh yeah, I remember now!
Yo, he's alive!
Ground floor.
Alright.
Time to go through chaos.
But where's the chaos?
Does he not spawn here?
I guess he spawns in the next one?
Ever-shifting chambers, realign.
That's what I'm saying.
If you kill a demon, like, can he just respawn back in hell?
Like, if you, like, technically can't die.
That's like what I'm thinking.
Like, how do you kill something that's dead?
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I fucking got hit twice by it.
Alright, let's go through the chaos.
Depends on the lore.
But for next...
Each time you attack, you take...
That is literally my entire...
kit you get oh plus 100 okay i just can't cast
100 resources yeah 66 chance to find uh i don't need a cast
yeah i gain a lot of hp though we'll get half yeah i like
that 100 okay i just can't cast okay that's the the worst
one
oh my god i wish i this is actually really good if i could
cast right now oh wait no it's fine that's right get
sunlocked oh yeah that's right sunlocked time traitor is
rich it's fine i don't think i gifted him anything i'll gift
him now lord he's dead what do you i was like oh man i sucks
i can't cast and then he's just dead He could be even he
could have died even faster
According my 10 for the maid cafe now see you tomorrow.
I'm ready.
Thank you.
Let's reach out to you.
I'll be enjoying the maid cafe I'll be enjoying the food
there too.
It looks so good I'm in your debt for this Hephaestus.
Yeah.
Oh, I got the shard.
That's what I needed Wait, he gives shards?
What?
Oh shit, I could have even more mad.
Yeah, this one.
That's from the damage I already do.
Always use more.
Yeah, I have like even more damage now.
Oh shit, that time.
It's me.
Hello, father.
He visited me recently.
Yeah, I do 500.
I tell him where to find you.
I made clear I did not know.
drawing more of his attention why don't he just like get a
guy to follow me you're saying he tortured you that blasted
wretch you won't need to find me i'm about to find him
that's right i'm gonna kill him for the fifth time it's john
haynes it's crazy the haiti is not even based off of his
kids he's such a deadbeat he even gets the game named after
himself Like, I wish I wasn't born.
I know the tales of how you vanquished him, but no so little
of how it was for you.
Yeah, why doesn't he turn back time and watch where you came
from?
We often fought.
He believed we would take after him.
None of us did.
What a child he is?
I just decided that the time had come for us to rule in his
stead.
He resisted bitterly.
But these old memories...
Aw.
I would leave them buried.
Yeah.
restore life for one percent damage you deal until you reach
the limit after you take okay deal more based on how many
times you used i don't even oh i mean if i none of this is
good so i guess i'll get three for the prophecies that i can
spare you honor me can i pet you now is it because i keep
beating you up understand The once feared Underworld King
resembles now the wretched and the damned that here was
shackled in his stead.
Until the scheming Titan Kronos cut them loose.
I don't understand.
Why does he never let me pet him?
It's not my fault.
He was a bad boy.
He literally tried to kill me first.
Alright, nice.
What the fuck?
chaos oh my god forgot i can't cast i it's like what the hit
me i forgot i was like i thought it was like one hit or some
shit oh it sucks that actually sucks that i can't cast
because i don't know where the fuck things are bro please
just die there you go
Mining, mining.
Uh, three.
We'll grab more money.
It's okay.
I have, like, double it.
Oh, my God.
That cooldown is so good.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Okay, technique.
No, I don't need a heal.
Not yet.
Two second shit is, like, clutching it.
I'm just all damage.
All damage, no defense.
Yay, money!
Uh, down I go.
I think I need, what, two more?
I mean, wait, am I good now?
Oh, shit.
Wait, can I cast now?
I can't, no.
I've lost count.
I have not been counting.
Oh, I can cast now.
That's good.
Oh, yeah, I can!
It's been so long.
I don't even remember what the word was.
Okay, nice.
What did I...
Oh, it was HP, right?
Oh, my God, I have so much HP.
Okay, now I definitely remember.
I don't remember.
I have a lot of health.
I was like, oh, my God, that does not look normal.
Alright, nice.
I was like, yeah, wait a minute.
This does not look normal.
Am I supposed to have that much health?
Okay.
Two tab.
Goodness.
Okay, we'll break that first.
Bro, let's just...
I can get this out of the way.
Magic!
Oh!
Alright.
Oh my god, okay.
I might have got a little bit...
I got a little cocky there.
I thought I just...
I don't know.
I thought I just lived.
I thought I could tank it.
Technically, I could.
Okay, one chamber.
There's so much...
These guys are so tanky, though.
Alright, nice.
Jesus, I didn't even see him.
You know what?
Fuck it, I'm just gonna heal just for the sake of it.
I know I only have one heal left, but that's fine.
That's all I need.
One heal and a dream.
Okay.
Alright, I have 1,300.
Okay, what the fuck is this?
Oh, it's plus three upgrade.
Um, yeah, but I can't afford this, though.
Is that just moon?
What's this up?
That's the moon, right?
Moon does?
Is it actually worth it?
What the fuck is it?
Oh, arcana cards!
Oh!
Okay.
Is it forever?
Does it buff it forever?
Okay.
Oh!
Alright.
I'll grab that.
Uh...
We don't need heals.
I guess we can buy this.
What's this again?
Is this like random?
Random.
Random, right?
Oh.
Got it for a discount.
Okay.
I just got this for a discount.
Let's go.
The scorch effect deals damage faster.
I think I need two.
Yeah.
And then, fuck it.
More HP.
I might as well.
Plus 60.
Yeah, fuck it.
I mean, I could grab full HP right now.
But, nah.
Grab this.
Technically, it's the same.
Okay, let's go in.
Nah.
Yeah, but then my...
If I die, if I die, I get more back.
Because I have the golden tooth.
That's right.
I'm back.
You, with all that vengeance on your mind, claiming to care
nothing for the family which I denied you.
Good, because you certainly did not miss much.
It had nothing for our family either.
And who's this?
rot you are no different i mean my family cares you alone
they just didn't care about you come on they left you to rot
because you gave them every reason to hate you it's salt
power i refuse to share they have not worked for it perhaps
if they asked nicely none of oh he's like bill gates there
is no undoing past mistakes but like not i'm not saying bill
gates is as evil as cronos i'm saying that he decided He was
like, I'm not going to give my sons any money because they
didn't work for it.
He was like, I'm going to, when I die, I'm going to donate
all my money to charity.
But like, I'm saying that he's like the, let Bill Gates,
it's like, you know, the evil version of Bill Gates.
I have to say he's like the evil version of Bill Gates,
guys.
I'm not trying to imply that Bill Gates is Kronos, guys.
That's not what I'm trying to fly.
Oh, I fucked up.
Oh, fuck.
I fucked up.
I did not see that.
Alright.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, my God.
I'm, like, tanking everything, apparently.
Alright, okay, we gotta get rid of these, though.
Oh god, oh god, I'm getting hit by all the Toho's.
Alright, that's fine.
Oh shit!
What the fuck?
Okay, I'm getting hit by everything.
Nice.
Kratoski, please.
Yeah, look at this.
You're weaker now Look how weak you are It took you six gods
to die, but now you're dying from one child And that was I
say about you, bro God damn it.
Oh my god, I'm taking everything.
Oh
Yay depth of fire.
Okay, I have two more.
I have two more.
I have two more guys.
It's okay.
It's okay I have two more, guys.
Okay, I might be getting a little too cocky right now.
What the fuck?
Oh, God, that was scary.
Oh, my God!
Okay, that's cheating!
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Guys, you don't understand.
I'm like, I'm confused.
I'm confused.
See, I have one more depth of finds, guys.
I still have one more.
Oh my god.
Wait, where is he?
Oh, it's okay.
I made it
Yay!
I didn't throw.
I just knew I had enough damage to face tank everything.
It's not throwing.
With them, you say, not us.
You too are a reject daughter of Hades.
A reject?
And always would have been.
I'm not a reject.
You just fucking took my family away.
It's not rejection if you fucking stole my family.
If anything, my brother's the reject.
His mom left him, not me.
The most HP is a research fight I've ever seen.
I fell in.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So much, dust.
All right.
Go back into the realm.
To the face of the subconscious, I descend.
Yeah, see?
I still had HP, guys.
night and darkness guide me to my blood beyond the grasp of
time
yeah that's me yeah as me hello again sister you wanted me
to search for signs of chronos preparing for a big surprise
and while it isn't much i did locate machinery and tartarus
that seemed a little out of place oh machinery you mean the
gears that turn the ever-shifting chambers in my time that
machinery is spread through Tartarus as far as I can see
what do you make of it well normally I wouldn't have made
anything of it but perhaps it's connected to what you're
saying I'm working on tracing where it leads what about you
any word on how we ought to proceed we need a weapon the
problem is that Kronos can resist the arms once used to
vanquish him on top of that it needs to be available both to
mine closer to our family the better can you think of
something suitable oh we're gonna make a weapon guys I have
some mortal weapons in my chambers but they hardly worked at
any point a weapon both in my time and in yours and none of
the infernal arms will do give it some thought but please
make haste Kronos shall realize what I'm up to here
eventually and this connection weakens every night for now
I'd better go hold on what happened the servants of this
house to my friends loves damn to be fair as a god there's
no such thing as monogamy as a god but loves of my life damn
zayrus well no um hypnosis with us but fast asleep yeah he's
a boy sure is bro he literally has a poster of his fucking
cousin.
I'm not in his room.
This guy, this boy's a freak.
Oh, at least the good commander Skelemias made it out.
But Nick's Achilles Thanatos, Megara, Deucer, Orpheus.
Jesus, that's a lot of names.
How many?
How many did you use?
I understand he's trapped the others, frozen them in time.
But we can break his hold on them.
I'm certain that we can.
Goodbye for now, brother.
Think of a weapon we can use to set this right.
All right Bye Zagreus Bro, he even he he's a freak He even
dated a head a floating head That boy's a freak Glad to be
back here with you, but it's a new night.
Bye Zagreus You think that you achieved a victory which um
Prolonged your demise for the Titan whom you vanquished
possessing but the smallest fraction of my power yeah she
all right i'm surprised and humbled that you damed to pay my
meager accomplishments any heed oh spirit yeah how did you
know i am all knowing also the shades out there were going
off about it some of them are right outside the tent oh my
god you guys are gossipers out there i think don't diss
medusa i'm not dissing her i'm just saying i'm I don't think
Zagres will date anything.
Dutifully organized and immaculately clean.
Like, he need no body, apparently.
A head is fine enough for him.
Yeah, gossiping shades.
Shake my head.
Good evening, everyone.
There's something new here.
Alright.
What else do you need?
Sassy victory.
We heard about the Titan's latest misfortune by your hand.
Proceeding as intended by your estimation I think so We just
need to find a suitable weapon now And then everything
that's come to pass So progressive Perhaps not everything
But plenty You know the rest by heart And I'll not pry for
further details But should an unexpected I don't know maybe
stop fucking fighting me Hecatee?
Like we're on the same side I don't need no test no more
Here's a thought Rich soil need it gives me more stuff to
plant okay do i have the seeds though for it jesus fucking
christ that's a tumor i like what the fuck some weed hey god
that's that's just a tumor taking matters into a very
capable hands not making too much grief for you i reckon so
you know already and like i just gave that plant fucking
cancer this is being nemesis discovering firsthand our task
is not as simple as it seems say no more than though if she
becomes too intent on impeding your results over achieving
her own we'll step in yeah it won't come to that i shall my
lord until then we each have our tasks to complete All
right, I should have more psyche here.
Yay!
Uh, what?
Oh yeah, I gotta get my fishing pool.
I just need two, right?
Yeah, I did not farm a lot of ash this time.
Uh, I gotta check up on this.
Wait, let's grab the...
How many do I need?
A lot of fishing?
Yay!
I can fish now!
Okay, this needs...
I don't even know how to grab it.
I guess they're like, oh, they're on the surface, right?
Alright, so I'm going to get the Tooth Defiance for now.
Okay.
A boon.
It's like, oh, for a Hef.
Okay.
This is for a Hef.
Alright, so...
Upgrade again.
Um...
We don't want to grab this.
Nope.
Oh, I need that.
What can I up?
I can't.
get any i mean technically i can activate this i guess i can
farm some stuff 45 all right let's see
uh do i need more ash i feel like i just farm more uh i'll
just spend it on i'll sparring it on psyche uh spend it on
psyche and then what do i need okay We need moss.
I could just plan for the nightshade, but...
We'll grab moss right now.
Do I have enough for Sherrod?
I don't know.
Let's check.
Another two credit cards.
Oh, I do!
Alright, more psyche.
Psyche is always good.
Yeah, we're gonna go for the...
We're just gonna farm moss and then get downstairs.
Regardless whatever happens the world now holds the key to
the once water gateway is gonna find moss and then die But
how is she to fare in that forbidden realm?
We'll find time Wait, how did you what?
How did you what?
I will not fail.
Oh, there you go.
We did it We did it.
We suddenly grow the other one though to be here little star
Your cursed blood shall fight your every step.
Yet Nix herself would understand.
Okay, we still need to grow the fucking tumor plan.
Alright, your pecs makes everything else move slower.
Fuck it, we'll just grab this.
It doesn't matter, we're gonna fucking pass out anyway.
So we're just gonna do this as fast as we can.
Because I'm just gonna get passed out soon.
Does it matter if I grab money?
Oh, there you go.
There we go.
Oh, God, not the birds.
Who would have thought the birds are...
Does more damage than the fucking demons?
Okay.
Why are the birds stronger than the fucking ghosts?
The birds are the true demons.
Taxiomar damage.
And oh my god, he gave me Ice Strike too.
Alright.
I'll go as fast as I can.
Whoops.
I don't know.
We'll go in here.
I don't think I'm gonna live too long.
Because all the enemies are so fucking strong.
But...
I don't know.
I think I'm dead in here.
Yeah, I ain't doing so well.
I'm gonna die so fast.
Moonbeam!
With the power of the moon!
It's all I have!
Oh, goodbye.
I'm dead.
Goodbye.
It's okay.
I have... Oh, never mind.
Wait, Death Defiance doesn't...
What's the point of having death defiance if I just die?
I can't defy my death.
Oh, it's only in hell.
Everything okay there, Mal?
Oh, yes, Dora.
It's just...
I should have gone farther that time.
Death acceptance.
I'll give more notes on your haunting later, alright?
Oh, it's because the fate decided.
That's crazy.
All that you take from the earth shall be returned.
The fate was like, no.
You said before, you think Kynos is going to influence the
weavings of the fates.
You mean he's going to try to change the future.
Force a favorable outcome.
Even though the fates are literally kidnapped right now,
they're like, nope.
Well, she's trying to save us.
Let's make it harder for her.
Unfortunately.
Yeah, see, the fates are a bit too hard.
We have headstrong.
Headstrong.
I trust they may be quite resistant as captives.
And no shit, they're not even trying to make this easy for
me to save their ass.
Or anybody else.
How he must hate them.
When he was overthrown before, that was the outcome of a
fated prophecy.
Yeah, they're actual rage baiters.
As for now, I sense there are no weavings happening at all.
No new futures foretold.
Kronos believes he has no prophecy to fear.
Oh shit, he literally stopped the future.
opportunity for you to make a look at who oh hey eras you
fucking bitch i thought i'd be there to see your face again
since i'm welcome here and safe still aren't i though it has
been a little while it's not been long enough much as i
wished you'd grown past your child preach it in milinois i
can't imagine you've returned for any reason other than to
keep it up what you can't imagine i just want to visit my
big sister if not you I get it, you're still mad, I slowed
you down.
Yes, I am still mad!
You've made my stream six hours long!
Longer than it should be!
What do you mean?
Oh, are you still mad that I made you stream like 10 hours
straight?
I mean, she didn't make me stream, but I could have finished
it.
I could have fucking beat Kronos like in three hours.
Oh, don't worry, I'll be fine.
I know those woods out there like the back of my She gave us
content I'm always grateful for your hospitality great
tightness And you are welcome here and safe, Arachne Now I
must beg your pardon The matters that unfold of late require
more of my attention than I'd like I truly understand Then
I'll get out of your hair Why is she here?
Yeah, go back to your home She's like, I'm here to clean my
dinner.
Oh, yeah.
I have to give her stuff too.
Look, I do want you to feel welcome here and safe.
It's not just something about to give her free stuff.
Thank you, Ares, for giving us more time with the bird.
Gavin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why don't you take this?
It isn't much, but I've been holding on to it in case I
found a friend.
does not do that a friend does not over another friend
necessary but um thanks bitch that's right i'm still so okay
four two okay i need four more rooms i'm making fast fast
travel that
i never could delve into the abyss of the subconscious with
you asleep with my brother the all right let's go oh what's
this i can i know what the can i do i mean i could just buy
a car i'll just buy cards yeah i do not have enough insight
i'll just keep buying cards and open everything golden apple
where the am i gonna farm that all right Press enter?
My altar.
Do I have anything to upgrade?
Oh, I do.
Oh, I have six.
Um, I'm making it too deftified.
You know, fuck it.
I see it now.
Yep.
Yeah, I'll grab another deftifiance.
Okay, now that I know.
But also take that much more.
Oh, I'm like basically...
Basically, oh, okay.
You ain't a random commons chaos blessing.
Like, does it really fully win your exilocation?
Okay, none of this actually matters because it's like, I'm
only alive for the...
You know what?
Yeah, let's fuck it.
Let's grab this.
I'm only alive for like three seconds anyway in here, so
let's go.
Commander?
Well, commander?
Yeah, where did the commander go?
All right, up we go.
Okay.
yeah I become a glass cannon which is basically all my runs
anyway okay it doesn't matter what we take we're just gonna
die too bad we couldn't scour the place before you got here
though we're right in the middle of a big shake-up fuck it
I'm picking whatever we're not gonna live long enough to
fucking realize what's going on like yeah so are we who are
we trying the pool here.
I literally take five steps and I get a heart attack.
There you go.
There's five steps.
Yep.
Nice.
Your tracks up here seem ill-advised, Militory.
I trust you have some sort of plan.
Yeah, my plan is to die.
Go ahead, die, repeat.
We're in the fucking Groundhog Day right now.
attacks inflict blitz I mean does it really matter what my
fucking thing does all right inside we go oh my god this
yeah if I can go to two one more room after this oh my god
my armor is actually saving my life right now oh my god my
armor is actually clutching it for me.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, armor's almost gone.
Okay.
What the fuck is this?
Wait, am I supposed to destroy that?
Like, oh shit, is that what's summoning it for all the
creatures?
Oh no.
Yeah.
Oh, 29 HP.
Prime.
150.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, that's new.
Oh, I got this.
Oh, one more step and I'm down.
Hmm.
Part of the barrier is down.
Must have been that pylon I destroyed.
So what?
Five more to go.
All right.
Here we go.
10 HP and a dream.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, I forgot.
Oh, I should have ran to the well.
I forgot about the well.
There's to be a way I can survive up there.
Does that know?
My plants grow?
The air up there did not sit well with me at all.
What, better than I expected.
You who ventured into my abode shall suffer an eternity of
torment for what you have done.
Unless, of course, you are prepared to grant my dying wish.
You're already dead, Dora.
To name your price, I am prepared to do your bidding.
Yeah, what do you want?
You can reason anyway.
Then swear to me that you shall do my bidding now.
Specifically...
I haven't worked out the dying wish part yet.
Ask you to fetch my lover's bones.
Something like that.
Do you even know how you died, Dora?
Just keep me posted.
And then, like, in some Dora, like, the people who died
forget how they died.
For some, like, um...
Macking even so much will.
Merely linger in a single place.
for some like myths and stuff like when you die and you're
in you're in hell you don't remember how you die because you
go into the river that makes you forget not happening
princess i'd ask what my sister eris is doing here but then
they say wheresoever goes doom strife follows or the other
way around whether i like it or not has she been here long
some people die when they are You don't...
Your death is not because you got killed?
Murder is not the only reason people die, guys.
They've been trained together, though.
Headmistress soon gave up on her, as patient as she is.
I know, it's crazy.
The fates gave up on her as well.
Ordered that we never interact.
That I not clean her messes anymore.
What?
Although sometimes she'll go to conversation out of me.
I trust she hasn't made your lives too difficult.
I've managed.
You're awake.
Have I...
Oh, nice!
Two more planets, finished.
Okay.
I need more nightshades?
Or is that enough?
I'm not the sort to dwell too much about what the three
fates may have in store for this goddess.
But I do have a bit of fabric we attribute to their work.
Free fabric!
Yay!
I love free stuff.
Fate fabric.
Few better ways to ensure the quadrant properly conducts a
magical effect.
I could definitely use this if you'd be so kind.
Oh, I'm not a kind.
Yay!
Okay.
Oh, shit.
I ran out of Nightshade.
I literally just need Lightshade.
Or Nightshade.
God damn, I need one more.
Can I trade this for Nightshade?
No.
Fuck!
I literally just need...
This will take a little while.
I literally just need Nightshade.
That's literally it.
mistress.
Olympus seems reluctant to ask outright, but I can tell my
family there needs me.
I cannot shake the sense that I have to help them before I
can achieve our task.
You needn't shake that sense, for it may well be accurate.
You're still thinking of an incantation that may help you I
need you one more run.
I think I'll do it at the bottom and just do it.
Like I can just like give up, right?
Give up a run.
I'll be like a fish out of water, right?
Suffocating.
But with a proper incantation, I was thinking maybe I could
hold my breath.
Just hold my breath.
That's crazy.
Just don't breathe the toxic H, like O2 air.
I was saying just don't breathe H2O.
That's why.
Magic such as that.
She'll help you go farther still.
I'm counting on it.
Guys, just hold your breath.
Does headmistress know yet of your little excursions?
Not much escapes her notice last night.
checked strongly advise you mind your own responsibilities
hekatee doesn't control me and you should show a little you
don't do anything you all you do is kill still i didn't ask
for your assistance nemesis yeah what assistance because
you're weak whoa that's it i'm angry now all right we're
just gonna do five rooms and then i i get hit like just
don't get hit i'm gonna to get hit all right where is it
glass cannon time all right i just gotta breeze through five
rooms and then and then like and then go back and grab my
nightshade yeah what does this bro even do this guy thinks
he's part of the team all right we're gonna pick random
patience you needn't be a witch to see your families in dire
straits right now you needn't be a witch at all if you ask
me i'd Another way of life, if I were you.
Here you go.
I'm picking random, guys.
I'm picking random.
Don't...
If I...
If I pick something bad, I'm picking random.
Okay.
Go.
We gotta get five rooms.
Okay.
I don't know what I'm picking.
I don't grab the money.
All right, Apollo.
No being run this time.
Wait, does Kronos...
Does the Kronos room count?
As a room?
Does it?
But even our Uncle Poseidon's affable veneer is a ferocity
I've learned to carefully avoid.
If he's backed you with his ocean strength, you're better
off.
Go make most of it.
Does the Chaos Room count as a room?
Your attacks deal more damage.
Your special.
All right, go in.
Oh, it doesn't cancel it.
Oh, okay.
So serene.
Oh, there's three holes now.
Oh, my God.
Just realized his arm has a face.
Jesus.
Oh, my God.
His arm has three faces.
This is so...
I like how his earrings is just the earth.
It's like earth is the only thing they care about.
Uh...
afterwards your special deal is 94 damage oh my god that's
fine i can do that uh hermes
i mean it's the baby level like there's no way i can not get
this it's really the baby level for babies yes so rams
somehow got hold of the three fates that isn't good not sure
what we can do about it m At least now everybody on Olympus
knows.
I figured it was time.
Got us a bit on edge, though we do hide it pretty well.
Alright.
Yeah, no more future prediction for you.
Okay.
When you stay afloat, do you have more damage with your
weapon for the next 45 seconds?
I mean...
That's really strong.
Bonus damage per slain flow.
Oh!
Wait.
Yeah, that's a lot.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Gold tab.
Guys, I think I...
I don't know if I'm doing a good job.
Wait, where's the...
I swear to God, if I made up...
And then doing a god build after this.
Yeah, no, she is.
She's not a good friend.
She says she's our friend, but I think she's a really bad
friend.
If only she was more like you How humiliating that even our
booms must be concealed Like who the fuck does that plus 90%
damage just because I'm better than her at gaming Like
Yeah we'll grab that Here you are It flows your tax deal
more damage in a larger area There you go Oh fuck it let's
get Poseidon I might, like...
I don't know.
I don't even know if I'm doing good.
Like, I can't tell if my build is strong or not.
We'll have to do this again.
When you sprint, hit the foes.
Remove your...
Move McHugh.
Briefly restore any...
After your attacks...
After the start, attacks are special.
Press and hold...
Oh, okay.
All right, one.
All right, next your tab.
Just waiting for me to die.
Oh, hey.
Nice.
Oh, yeah, I forgot.
I have the thing where, like, don't I have...
I have blast cannon on right now, right?
Can't do it.
Wait.
I don't even remember.
I brought the last cannon, right?
Oh, yeah, no, I'm fucking dead.
Yeah, no, I'm...
I'm gonna die soon.
I legit forgot what I had.
No, 100%.
I'm gonna die soon.
I hate you, you can ask, but have you picked up any trace of
Zagreus by any chance?
Well, in your father's house?
Oh, yeah, I talked to him.
It's hard for me to say.
My brother isn't there, but I sense...
Yeah, I talked to him in the seat.
It's not crazy or anything.
Oh, I forgot to give...
No, I already gifted her.
Didn't that when she was singing?
He better be alright.
The choice is yours.
After you had fire seeking a arrow, you may deal critical
damage.
Sure, death warrant.
But...
I mean, it's 10 damage is nothing.
Together we shine.
Oh wait, what's this?
What the fuck was that?
Wait, what did I do?
Oh shit!
Oh, it's okay.
Receiving wretches.
Oh wait, nice!
$100.
Yeah!
My incantation must have led me to this place.
Deep in the endless woods of Erebus, lie secret clearings,
undiscoverable, but through supernatural means.
I knew we'd find this place.
Oh hey.
Oh, free water!
Can't tell if I have a good build or not, honestly.
Like, I have the glass cannon build.
I do do a lot of damage right now.
I think my plans are done, though.
Oh, hey.
Tiki time.
Do not be afraid.
I'm going to turn you into upgrades.
There you go.
Our uncle and I were just debating what to do about mortals
who turn their backs on us.
I think a year or so of plague should settle up.
Whoa.
A year?
That's pussy work.
Make it 10 years.
Make it 30 years so their kids' kids will die from the
plague.
Oh my god, they gave me due.
I might as well finish this run.
This run was supposed to be a throwaway run and then I got a
duo.
Alright, we're just gonna do it until we die.
Oh my god, okay.
We're surges ahead once you stop.
Now I'm fast as fuck.
Uh...
Like, I might just...
What the fuck is that?
I got a beach ball.
Actually, what the fuck do I have?
I'm so confused about this.
Okay, this beach ball...
Okay, I guess it's...
Oh, wait.
No, it's strong.
Yeah, no, that's strong.
I think it's like better when I'm like...
When I'm against the boss, I think.
Yeah, no, that shit is...
It's very strong.
Hammer.
Alright, well, we'll go until we die.
We'll see how this goes.
What a pretty nice build.
Your special games, your whenever you set forward restore
five I need a hose though
I don't know we'll grab two for the prophecy superior might
yeah there's not much glory in confronting adversaries one
to yeah may as well do it for the prophecy invoke shades of
the dead to alter the odds some may well favor you instead
Perhaps if I brought with me a legion of animal familiars
next time head mistress not that any be you just yet a
familiar May be of considerable benefit given all that you
have to do.
I mean it would be nice to have a pet To do most of the
tanking.
Can I just bring service a lot?
Jesus oh my god.
Okay, I broke my one armor
Well the armor is gone already
All right.
All right, where are the demons?
Boop.
All right.
Wait, where am I missing?
Oh.
Okay, I want to...
Oh, shit.
Okay, that strike thing is crazy.
Oh, my gosh.
She's almost dead already.
Oh, fuck.
I can't see.
It's all blue.
What?
What the fuck?!
I literally can't see the spell.
It's all blue.
It's just blue.
Okay, that's just...
That's just cheating.
My entire attack is just blue.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, she's here.
Yay!
Oh my god, my first time getting Deftified.
What if the spells were blue?
Do you bring an enemy familiar along next time?
If but to keep things lively for me.
I actually lost the Deftified.
Everything was just blue.
Faith of familiar spirits.
They should work on Freenos.
Oh, wait, nice.
die.
I don't want to play this run anymore.
Everything's just blue, and I think that's going to be bad
for me long term wise.
We'll just go.
We'll keep that.
We're just going to tank this until we're dead.
Here comes our shadowy assassin on her nightly escapade to
try and do... I think my build is too blue.
I'll be so fortunate at this time.
We'll soon find out, won't we?
I promise not to keep you waiting long.
I'm well on my way already as you- Oh, I keep it even if I
swap?
Oh, that I can.
Then I had best return and make ready.
We have to tidy up for your arrival after all.
Yeah, I'm coming back, but not this run.
I'm just gonna go die.
It's just too blue.
I mean, if I- oh, the effect will still stay?
I mean, fine, I'll just- I mean, fuck it.
Alright, I'm just gonna go tank it and die.
There's too much blue.
Alright.
Come at me.
Alright, I'll just stay here.
No, no, I'm not fighting.
I'm just here.
I'm just tanking this.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
It's almost there.
This area is literally all blue.
I cannot deal with that.
I just, just one more hit.
There we go.
Come on.
One more.
There we go.
I'm blue.
This fucking arena is all blue, guys.
I cannot deal with that.
At least we were in a green area.
But this one was just...
It's just everything is just blue.
Alright.
Let's make this.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Where's my planet?
There it is.
Yay!
I got my nightshades!
Bye-bye, beach ball.
Yay!
I can breathe now!
Release me from this realm.
Become my key.
I can go to the surface!
Okay, we'll do a surface run on the next place through,
guys.
Because I actually have to go now.
To prep for the maid cafe.
But!
We get animals now!
How do I do this?
To all my beast companions near and far.
I'll get pets!
I can breathe oxygen!
Wait, what happens?
Give to a beast.
Where are they?
Where are the beast at?
Take all the time you need.
We'll keep it safe.
How do I feed them?
We're...
Oh, can I give it to Froggy?
Hello, Froggy.
Bond.
Oh!
Come with me!
This is a very special treat, Fritos.
Come with me to hell.
Oh.
Oh, you can protect me?
Oh!
Wait, is he a tank?
Oh my god, I knew it.
Wait, how does...
it work how do i like exchange him for another pet oh he can
block the sheep spell oh that's oh there he is man oh he's
gonna come with me to the to the thing oh that's cute all
right we're gonna call it here guys i oh wait i can take him
to the training area okay wait i want you to Where does he
come from?
There must be something you could tell me of my brother.
The stronger my connection, the better our chances.
You knew him, didn't you?
I knew your brother, yeah.
Good kid most of the time.
He wouldn't want you to be so hung up about him.
What he'd want more than anything.
Oh no, that's weird.
Bro, that's weird.
As hard as you can, repeatedly and often, and that's what I
would want for you as well.
Bro, that's... Bro, that's fucking weird, bro.
Wow, no, that's...
That's weird, bro.
Wait, no.
Come with me.
Oh!
Look at him!
Wait, how does it work?
Oh, does he just tank the shots?
Is that his purpose?
Oh, my God.
Yeah, he's definitely a masochist, for sure.
That's freaking weird, bro.
Bro, you do not take your fetishes in the work environment,
bro.
You put that at home.
Hobbs about absorbing foes that must struck.
Oh, I get bonus health too.
Bonus chance of research.
Oh, wait, that's insane.
I wonder which is, like, the best pet you can get in your
run.
See, this is why I did the demon runs first before I went to
the surface.
Because I felt like the surface is much harder.
So I'd rather just, like, get all the Hades stuff, the
Kronos stuff.
All the Kronos materials first before I go up.
oh he autos this oh i don't even have to dodge it i'll just
let the frog take it yeah i feel like that was like the
easiest i need three more runs downstairs before i can do
the upstairs runs um but anyway i'm gonna go out here like i
said i said that like four times but i i have to prep for
the the maid cafe stuff because you know there's a lot of
stuff like i have So, oh my god, there's a lot of stuff I
need to prep for it.
Oh, I hope I don't fumble or mess up, because I always get
really nervous seeing karaoke live.
Oh, especially, like, like, at a cafe.
I think it's different.
If I'm sitting on stream, it's different, but, like, for the
maid cafe, I actually have to, there's, like, a camera there
that shows you guys.
Like, I'm like, oh my god, you're real people.
You're not bots.
Like, I'm like, oh my god, there's actual...
faces.
I'm not sitting towards the screen.
Like, you know, when I do karaoke on stream, I look at
myself.
I'm like, instead, I can't look at myself.
I look at, I look at you guys.
No, not hurtful.
I'm just like, oh my God.
I'm not, you guys are real people.
I'm not, you're not view bots.
You're real people.
Oh my God.
It just turned off the screen, bro.
Like, yeah, so I get even more nervous like oh my god real
flesh anyway guys i have an hour until an hour until the
cath the tech rehearsal so i gotta go get ready as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check yeah i'm around to get
that blood flowing you stand for me head to bed because you
deserve it i really want to stream more but like i said i'm
gonna make sure i don't push myself and also give myself
time uh to get ready for the tech rehearsal i hope you guys
had a fun time watching haiti's too i'll do i'll do the
surface run in the next stream um we'll definitely have a
more endurance stream for the next 80s one because i like i
said i love roguelites and it's like it has a fucking grip
on me every time um goodbye everyone bye bye guys bye wait i
already set the i forgot if i set the outro my brain is so
all of
i'll say it again as always ready to say hydrated posture
check get moving around get that Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye